foreign
[Music]
let's go
foreign
[Music]
questions
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
two one here we go
foreign
[Music]
let's go
foreign
[Music]
oh
I'm gonna have to do it
what's good Turtle Squad it's your boy
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
he has to move his brown man whoa you
could do that I can't move your crown
man like that
they have this chest rabbit that's just
terrible oh
it's POG Champs POG Champs five baby we
are Live Another Day is about to get
underway Danny wrench here alongside
Hikaru Nakamura as well as someone else
sitting in front of him
[Music]
sorry I was hearing
what's about test streams starting off
with Hikaru in the back and Andrea botez
sitting in front and uh can I just can I
just compliment you on the greatest the
greatest
cardboard printout of all time
oh thank God okay I fixed Danny I was
hearing a hundred of you in my
headphones okay yes I'm very excited um
you know I was just telling Danny that
you know when I was a little girl and I
would play in chess tournaments my
father would come behind my tennis games
and he would lurk and he would put extra
pressure on me to perform and um I feel
like Hikaru lurking is just the next
best thing always watching Always
judging not with us in this POG Champs
but here in spirit and we've got a lot
of players with us this POG Champs we've
seen mostly action from group a and
Group B today we got a lot of group C
ahead uh and uh you're you're a guy I
say that because you've been coaching
him a bunch ghastly sitting there atop a
group
blessed let's not let's not forget that
uh top is my student and second top of
group E is my student I'm very proud to
say that snap that fidget check made his
last opponent in five moves
um I will not mention or disclose who he
took chess lessons with before that game
all I have to say is these are my
prodigies
they are your prodigies and there's
someone else and actually there's two
other players in that group making their
debut today and I think one of them may
end up being a favorite for the whole
thing but let's let's dive in to start
things off we have squeaks as we said
making his POG Champ's debut against
Ginny and then we have virtual who uh
you know I know sapnap is uh is the guy
who you were saying you've been working
with and I know he's motivated but
virtual might be one of the best players
in the entire event
um and then quickly after that we have
squeaks will go up again against Tyler
um and uh we know that that should be
interesting and Jarvis versus Sky Kuno
Andrea who are you most excited to see
maybe if the two players making their
debut between squeaks and virtual
between squeaks and virtual I have to
say I am going to root for squeaks
because Mr virtual I was doing some
digging today you know looking into his
uh test history and there's some very
suspicious things first he plays the cow
and that speaks for itself and then
second he had a YouTube video called my
editor shoots type the bow Test sisters
and in the video he starts it with oh
there's Alexandra Bose and then his
Mouse slowly hovers to me and he's like
uh and that's uh and then he just
doesn't know my name therefore I am
rooting for squeak we shall be maybe
another Prodigy of mine I love that I
love that well there you go caught on
camera not knowing uh Andrea botez we'll
uh we'll see we'll see how he does today
you can go after him in the interview if
we talk to him but let's let's talk a
little bit about squeaks this is a guy
who uh a lot of people know for his
speed running he was actually nominated
in the 2023 streamer awards for his
speed run for his speedrun abilities I
I'm jealous of that Mario 64 for placing
that's uh that's a pretty hot record
right there but and I would like to add
an additional fun fact
he also has 60
6 very important
let's let's keep it that way nobody else
subscribed to squeaks forevermore on
YouTube and we'll keep him at 69 000
subscribers looks like he's asleep at
the desk there on that little animated
animated thing of himself and uh he's
already alive
he's a speedrunner guys he has been
first game in the tournament but he has
been playing like 10 games of Chess
every day he's waving to us he's been
grinding he's even back ranked Ludwig in
chess you know we're not going to see
how much material what there was on the
board but he's a dark horse
yeah when Ludwig wanted to invite him he
said he thought this guy would grind and
that he would probably be a lot better
at the end of the event than he started
so Luda lud sent the invite to squeaks
we're glad to have him let's talk about
who he's playing we got Jenny up and uh
Jenny has already played we know she had
that match versus Tyler earlier in the
event but uh since then she's probably
walked a hundred thousand steps and gone
to seven different cities and so she's
getting her exercise in in between chess
matches
different
how many hours playing chess however you
know as Magnus says physical fitness is
just as important for your best
repertoire so she is in good shape and
we will see how that does for squeaks it
looks like she's doing some last minute
prep here if this is her stream live I
don't know who she's watching and this
this position on the board with Queen
takes B2 my first piece of advice if
you're preparing a trap and you don't
want your opponent to fall for it don't
share it on stream no squeaks is a nice
guy who knows maybe he's not even
listening he doesn't even know
I I think he does know I think he is
listening yeah he's literally watching
guys he's literally watching right now
sweep up this is not even the opening
she's gonna play debate it you don't
even know squeaks you better just focus
on your own game but all right so we got
a lot of POG Champs ahead what has been
your favorite moments so far you
commentated on the day one with Levy
you've also been missed pod Champs
You've Been Everywhere you're coaching a
bunch you're commentating how excited
are you that the event is back
dude this has literally been the
sweatiest POG chimps ever like last
night I'm not gonna say who I get a call
from one of my students it's 9pm I'm
pretty tired I've been grinding they're
like Andrea I need you to help me
prepare for my opening my my opponent
tomorrow because possum helped my
previous opponent repair and now he was
super motivated to have like a trap so
we grinded pulled out the chest face did
all the digging I'm not gonna say who I
prepared but my students are are
studying so I hope it motivates the rest
of the competition and do the same yeah
and I think they will the event has just
got going often you see most of it most
of it gets serious once they start
playing and sometimes losing their chess
matches then they start working a little
bit harder but all right let's quickly
remind the fans we've already got a
whole bunch here of the format they know
and love for those of you who have been
following POG Champs
not uh nothing's changed here two rapid
games that means you get to play with
each color 10 minutes plus five second
increment we do that to make sure that
not too many games will be lost on time
it's first to one and a half points but
if we are tied at one game a piece of
course we will have a blitz tiebreaker
the most exciting event in the world of
course is just High break so stick
around for that now you just said I I
wanna I wanna end this once and for all
do you want people to call you Andrea or
Andrea
um well my sister when she's angry says
Andrea and that's actually
um what I was born with my parents are
Romanian but please don't call me Andrea
so either other way works so Andrea and
Andre are fine yeah you could just
okay that sounds even better no that's
that's honestly lame
no
no one dates you just
keep my way into title Tuesday maybe if
like you know one of my podcast students
win the tournament just just once I
could play title Tuesday you know I'm
with you I I would I would love it for
the content but then I worry about you
know the guys that are grinding to win
it you know one of them in a full
cardboard cutout behind you if they you
know if they don't feel good about you
know so I need we need to think about
this let's think about an event okay I
just wanted to put it out there okay
yeah all right well here here we go
we've got Jenny we've got we've got
squeaks we've got action we've got E4 on
the board here we go yeah I'm curious
how long Ginny's been streaming today
last time she was on like a seven hour
streak and she had one of the longest
games in pogchamp's history so hopefully
hopefully she's a little less um
because I don't even know what the word
I was going for but you know go ahead
well I think they're both live too
because not everyone is always streaming
live so sometimes they're just on Zoom
although I've noticed that some of the
people on Zoom actually talk even more
than when they're streaming like they're
just talking to themselves but they're
just yapping away and it's some of the
best content so I can't wait to see what
squeaks and Jenny are saying today
yeah no I I assume Ginny Jenny's opening
last time was some very creative
openings it looks like she did a little
bit of prep because today she's playing
an opening a real opening
6.5 hours as well chat just said wow
she's been she's been live for six and a
half hours yes I think squeak just woke
up bright and early just started this
day but you need the machine just got
the stamina
move two she's still in the book don't
you worry this is all part of the crap
part of the five minute crash course
should play B6
it's not a bad move by the way I mean
this is you know unorthodox a little bit
but nice little feet and Kettle coming
I I hear chill music which I really love
there's nothing better than a stream
with some chill music
oh you're hearing the stream okay I'm
not hearing anything I will fix
no I think she's just not talking that's
all I just need to remember where are
you hearing the music are you just
hearing things maybe maybe I'm just
hearing you
should work hopefully they work she has
opening streaks to win right in the tab
like you know I don't know that it's
gonna help her in this one because she
played an opening that no one knows as
far as leaning into my mic here just see
if I don't know why leaning into my mic
made me think I would hear it better but
I thought there was music in the
background am I crazy yeah no I I either
chat you guys hear the music display
music okay that means I'm not hearing
the broadcast because I was hearing
double Danny but um
fix that the worst type of Danny to hear
double Danny
um
all right well we've got a sicilian I
mean if we want to if we want to talk a
little bit about it this is a chest show
you've got it you got it you've got some
stuff going on here I'm not sure that
it's going to do anything but squeaks
we'll see how aggressive squeaks tries
to get in the opening whenever F7 is on
the on the docket
I'm just troubleshooting one second
this is the calmest vibe to start a Pog
champ State we've got calm music not a
lot of talking
um
and uh oh and Knight H6 was played
perhaps inside yeah perhaps Jenny was
aware of F7 being weak but we see the uh
we see the question mark deservedly so
because that night is it's not a happy
pony over there you know I think she's
just learning from previous pogchamps
she's bringing an early defense for the
F7 squares which doesn't get mated yep
yep good stuff always avoid the uh the
Checkmate that may never come that's
good advice um
well Grandmaster botez
um
I will address you that way with Grand
Master and Kara Nakamura I'm so jealous
I went and got Hikaru just so I could
compete with you it's that's even better
honestly I've got a stack of Fat Heads
let me just pull up I've got my gym
shorts on because I plan on playing
pickleball right after this but let me
just
what is up with people in pickleball I
have to say chat we launched the servers
today and and Danny comes in and mind
you we're running late to the tech check
he is the CEO of chess.com production
teams waiting he's like hang on he goes
he returns with two floating heads
continues to spend like 10 minutes
trying to tape it to the wall just for
it to fall off but I hope you guys know
that Karu is always watching we'll play
your best chest with this this is this
is it mine meld with Hikaru Nakamura the
greatest thing you can ever do for your
chest I kind of look a little princess
leia-ish with a car behind me and the
headphones yeah it's a good look you
know he's moving on in things in life
but we need him here in pogchan we have
some of his own Prodigy students
okay we've had we've had some craziness
on the board we've had F5 played this is
I don't think this is going to compete
with you know snap naps okay I actually
just did that accidentally don't come
after me sapnap I did I did it in
rehearsal too sapnap one in five moves
this isn't gonna be like that Andrea but
this is this is getting very dangerous
for for Ginny here yeah I always tell my
beginner students just don't touch the
f-pawn there's really no need to do so
but surprisingly Jenny putting her
Knight on the side of the board which
typically is terrible you always want to
develop towards the center may actually
save her from some sneaking mate on F7
which started as sarcasm but now it's
very much needed
okay squeaks has come to life here he
was chatting away there we'll see we'll
see if he's keeping at it
I mean this is a good move
[Music]
yeah he sees it
oh now the queen is exposed that makes
it even better move
I take
Queen moves here yeah I think that's a
good move
Queen moves here I'll take the Knight
the pawns double up
I don't see what's wrong with that
not bad
by the way Andreia
you notice squeaks is using I think the
Hikaru Nakamura board speaking of Hikaru
is with us he's with he's in your room
judging watching drinking coffee
handling our inner Hikaru you think
Jenny's channeling her inner Hikaru
I don't know I mean she wasn't watching
his YouTube videos Chad's yelling at me
for blocking hikaru's head apparently
they really want to see him all right
I'll let him be ever present I like it
more when he's lurking just one day so I
guess a little bit he's back can't just
think about what they want all the time
you know oh no Hikaru fell Hikaru fell
oh no okay he's still lurking he's still
there yeah he's here in spirit I'll get
I'll get hicaro up in a minute I don't
know that I should keep getting up so
all right we've got action we've gotta
captures on H6 but Jenny's holding her
own you know we don't have a lot of
Chess analysis here we should point out
that if this Knight were to move
we could get real
we could get real frisky real quick here
this queen comes into H5 so the pro the
one good thing that Ginny has going for
her Andrea is the Knight doesn't have
any obvious squares because black is
actually protecting so so squeaks would
have to really see the idea of getting
the Knight out of the way
somehow her unorthodox Pawn structure
like completely defends all the threats
of potential mates on F7 so I'm
optimistic yeah I agree you've got
you've got this Pawn chain blocking the
worst of it
Heck if you could get if you get the
king out of the way the G file becomes
an asset I don't know if it'll work
because Here Comes squeaks opening
things up but
being aggressive he's opening the sniper
soon but so far she's still safe but
this is getting very scary
yeah agreed
she's talking I think she I think she
knows that it's nerve-wracking let's
let's just try to tune in and see what
she's saying
see what Jenny's saying see if we can
hear her thoughts
Jenny Jenny
if I move this Pawn over here am I
losing something
not really
yeah not really
so I I think I can eat it yeah because
this one this bishop cannot do anything
this horsey cannot do anything as well
as this horse I cannot do anything and
queen is blocked by pawn and Knight and
then also Rook gonna go over yeah that's
all right
oh my God okay
she's stressed
so for my work she got what is that
noise but I do have Bishop
I think I'm gonna use my Bishop over
here no no
no if I move my Bishop over here to
threaten no it sounds like someone's
typing on a typewriter for the 1920s
that's me oh my God I'm literally an
idiot Danny I have been troubleshooting
my double audio and I just realized I
had the chess.com stream open in the
background I'm so sorry Chad I have been
like trying to nonchalantly fix this
realizing I was just being an idiot a
little bit
does that give me a little bit of uh
user error
that's okay
oh God
never know what they hear anymore if I
eat the pond and I can kill it and also
Queen can kill it which is probably not
I like Jenny's thinking face this is a
new one yeah I haven't seen this one yet
the finger across the nose
[Music]
her calculation is good then you can
even it's worse so and I could be with
this it he's horsey with my Pawn
foreign
so is he gonna trade
because we're both gonna trade it's
horsey
but then if he it's my horsey and I can
eat it
all right Ginny Ginny is in a little bit
of trouble here after the night takes on
D4
as she said
she can kill it the Queen's gonna kill
it and then I think she I think the way
she was talking she went as far as
seeing this idea
so although the computer just pointed
out that was a miss and the reason
everybody is that Queen H5 and queen of
seven was Checkmate in two
so uh squeaks already in the range of uh
of having checkmates on the board that
tells you how much trouble we're in here
if we're Jenny fans which we're all
Ginny fans
Andrea will be back shortly everybody
and we see uh yeah we see chat calling
out the Mr mate we see maybe squeaks
realizes it I don't know
but white is still totally winning here
we got this problem we got the queen
coming here problem
we got we got all kinds of problems here
and we're gonna listen into squeaks
let's do it
okay
that's definitely the move I can hear
you Andrea
okay let's not be scared now
it's a move not the move it's not a real
boat test stream if I don't just maybe
we bring in our other pieces
if I go here let the games begin we have
troubleshooting and dealt with audio
issues and squeaks is a moment away from
Checkmate he already missed mating too
but he's still in good shape or if I
move my Rook here and I take no no no no
no
if I move here what's Ginny gonna do
remember everything I say I saw how
she's the
gonna happen
here Jenny has to move her rook and then
it's Checkmate yeah right uh unless I'm
missing something I think he's a little
bit
hallucinating but we'll see I I if I was
just over
that's true there's only one movie there
still is
but Chad is just spamming Doritos
I wonder if they they even understand
I love seeing the spam chat of Doritos
by the way there we go now it's entering
the chess chat what does the Doritos I
don't even know what it means I don't
even know what it means I'm actually
balding here he comes right he sees
something I don't know what something
what's he drinking there is that is that
tea I lose enough hair I'm gonna start
playing League he's a
please don't play league we already we
already got Tyler in here we don't need
another
cat understands there's something
they're in that game
oh my God is he gonna boat says Gambit I
think he's gonna bow test Gambit
honestly kind of want to see it
he doesn't see the room he thinks he's
winning
if she doesn't do anything and I move
there boom
but I hope she moves I hope she moves
here it's not game over quite yet but
it's close
foreign
I think I need my Rook behind and then
[Music]
I actually don't know what I'm doing
and we're back on track
that's a Checkmate for me otherwise I
don't know what to do
[Music]
wait
there's nothing like confident analysis
suddenly followed by the honest
admission of I have no idea what I'm
doing that's kind of my strategy to
chess too but now his Rook move has
worked out but the bishop just goes back
hopefully they don't block with the
queen
yeah Ginny
Jenny's in check she looks stressed she
knows she's in trouble but maybe squeaks
will hallucinate a Checkmate and Go full
botes Gambit never go full botes Gambit
we've talked about that I I don't know
why but I'm feeling that there might be
one boat has Gambit today in this very
game but hopefully she pulls out the GM
card and brings the bishop back because
that's what GMS do they just bring their
pieces back
I'm sorry I I have to be honest I have a
hard time not just looking at hakara
behind you the whole time maybe it's
because I'm like scared I don't know
always
dude Hikaru is bringing the Grand Master
energy to these games so far but you
know the other night I was just sitting
working in the dark home alone and
sometimes like I just get jump scared
every second and I could just move him
out of the room but I feel like I would
be disrespecting him so he's just he's
gonna be there forever until he does sub
battles always watching
all right well she did put the bishop
back so that's good Jenny had the option
of blocking with the queen and she
didn't do that
um so game on it's not over yet
yep we'll see a little manifesting
squeaks Checkmate on F7 maybe a free
Queen who knows but he's been searching
for it
but Jenny is holding up very well I have
to say watching her match for Tyler the
other day
um Tyler was one move away from
Checkmate and then all the servers went
down so it took us like an hour for that
game to finish and then he missed the
mate so we were just slowly torturing
Ginny because it was kind of a lost
position so I would like to see it come
back from Ginny I agree that was that
was that was painful hopefully no more
no more attacks by bad people
um but okay people saying that there's
no way squeaks is 350. I agree he's
playing way better than his rating but
remember all these pogchamps ratings you
can basically throw away because most of
them haven't played enough to really
know how good they are and he is playing
a knight D5 was a great move yeah
right in the center that is a very
principled move no wonder he's beat
Ludwig
yeah
sometimes I think Ludwig just throws
games for Content yeah that's neither
here nor there too
well yeah wow okay he got the Rook F7
move he wanted but now it's actually our
best Her Best Move
even though yeah that was great is this
oh oh my god do you see it I see
something that you don't I see something
yeah I see it this Checkmate the
Checkmate too I do see it who moves yeah
this is no no no it's honestly
embarrassing that it took me so long to
see but this is a beautiful one
he finds it if he sees the next move
dude he looks so terrified she knows
she knows if he finds Knight F6 check
and mate my mind will be blown both of
them like you know you're fully focused
when you raise all your hands they see
it
okay
let's see if he sees it let's go to
squeaks we got to see this he's got he's
got hand out like this has got to be
made
bro oh
yeah he thought it was Checkmate no way
one minute now this is like the puzzles
I've been doing
you got this
what if I sack my queen hold on no no
yeah do it do it sexy for three minutes
let's take our time
I go here
take take
bad
he's missing here
check
but it's actually hard to see I mean he
thought the last position was Checkmate
but the Rook is pinned and the bishop is
pinned everybody so it's it's mating one
it's check
Queen takes I take the queen still
winning
hmm
that Line's not as good because white
would lose his Queen oh my God he's
missing the mate he set it up so
beautifully
wait is this a good play I think this
might be a good play but I don't want to
waste time
I just want to keep Ginny in check he
just said this is the most important
position
he only has two minutes far away so if
he doesn't find this this is not over
Ginny is in it did he couldn't flag him
remember she's a she's a speed machine
never has there been made on the board
and uh maybe more confident he's not
gonna find it I think there's a good
move oh my god dude oh my God I took
with the wrong piece oh my God
that wasn't like winning he could have
taken with check he had night check
okay anything remember what I said the
queen
oh my gosh
oh
okay
you're happy about it okay there you go
but so what
you cannot really kill my queen king can
you so
I love the nursery Tunes playing
yeah this is the most interesting music
selection to play chess to
oh because of this okay
because of Bruce okay I was like why
can't I move other stuff I didn't see
you look at squeaks though
he quickly plays Knight takes
oh my God she's gonna find queen of sex
kill kill horse I'm gonna move look at
suddenly Jenny is ballinaire now black
is winning
yeah
I think she has 30 seconds
I am a little concerned oh my God not
the camp she's third is come on Jenny
just you got this this is your game
we've been waiting for this moment this
is what you deserve after that 90 minute
torture
playing fast I think she I think she
knows she's gonna die there you go
there's the look of someone who knows
she's about to flag and there's a gray
screen oh God not this again come on
okay I can't tell if she's disconnecting
or something's giving up
it's probably her stream because she's
been live for seven hours so yeah that
doesn't see you
she's just moving back and forth with
the queen she doesn't have a lot of time
she's got to get the bishop in the game
develop your Bishop on C8 what are the
chances you oh never mind I got excited
about Bishop B7 thought she could sneak
a mate on G2 but oh my gosh squeaks is
putting the pressure on
oh my God she has 15 seconds she has to
move her Bishop we need to defend the
square gotta move don't allow the back
ring check it's gonna get too dangerous
move the Bish move the
Bishops the queen
it's like she forgot she can play with
the bishop and Rook like she's just
completely forgotten they're on the
board when you're so tunneled in under
attack and with time pressured so hard
to look at the rest of the board
yeah this is an email bar up and down if
you're not used to that wardrobe welcome
to or what is it word drill champs for
her to discover the bishop so far it's
still a battle of just her King and
pawns versus the Rooks but when she gets
that Bishop bishop and that rook in the
game
you know losing but she only is just out
in exchange
no I mean POG champs this is POG champs
this is still very complicated if she
okay if she gets the bishop in the game
which she finally does now get the rook
in
Bishop C6 I know oh she has six seconds
anything Jenny anything
you gotta move two seconds one second
oh my God I don't know how she's not
having a heart attack right now playing
on just this increment
oh it's crazy is now white has Checkmate
in one with any check uh with the Rook
on the on the e-file oh man squeaks
didn't know about the increment
oh well he didn't need to because this
is unfortunately made in one
it's falling apart poor Jenny and she
goes down on time seconds
what is this game
they need to update it apparently
the amount of times I've heard people
just complain about rules of Chess I can
be there for hundreds of years
uh okay let me think if I go here
this is
this is not outside of Steel I can still
make territory it's called he's got a
checkmater but
easier things have happened
I don't want to get repetitioned
he knows he's aware
he's not good at checkmating on his own
chat says and I'm gonna promote it yeah
we saw that earlier actually
hanging in there
foreign
this is entering stalemate territory
there's just two more pause that's good
okay there you go he doesn't know the
ladder oh maybe I should know Nemo why
didn't you teach him the ladder he did
one chess lesson with the Grand Master
I'm gonna give her a call
she's in trouble oh he wins on time oh
God
the most anti-climactic result ever boom
I missed the mate in one oh I'm I messed
up so bad but I am happy with the mid
game I just don't know how to quickly
review okay let's see
oh you may not use analysis while
playing hey did I [__] this up am I not
allowed to do this I kind of want to see
him
check
am I long am I not allowed to do this I
don't know
it's fine because it's over okay
it will help
but yo thanks dude all right well
squeaks is gonna check out game review
and check in with us yeah I think I
played pretty good here I want to see
his reactions seeing me
go ahead Denny yeah he he I think he
just found out but we see the score
there everybody one oh oh man I just I
feel so bad for Jenny like she was so
close to getting her first step nothing
against squeaks I think squeaks is uh I
think squeaks is gonna be all right he's
gonna get better he's up a game yeah hey
yeah
yeah Jenny she was paired against
Thailand one who plays League of Legends
for a living and
a speedrunner he's been playing chess
like she's had some very difficult
matches but she has a lot of potential
and I think Cindy's gonna be taking some
dubs sooner or later
yeah I agree we're gonna go back to
squeeze and get some more game review
because this is fun to see he's uh
see the mates or are you still looking
I just check quoting these you know how
to speedrunner is that not what he does
dang it that's hard he is a speedrunner
you're right the end was so good I was
so scared
I just am not good at finding checkmates
hey guys well he's winning the one that
matters okay good day of playing chess
ah
this is my third day
so I'm learning I'm trying like is it
hard what is that thing I just took it
it's hard to see this is my jug
what are the chess Elites saying oh they
can't see oh God it's really cool I
assume that's the stream that's just
water oh no this is that's my hydration
like we said you know people that watch
wanna be the best GM ever players health
comes first so drink lots of water first
no I
mean I'm not saying anything bad I'm
saying like you know you put like some
vitamins in it like you know sometimes
you know I actually wish I did but it's
literally just water and people always
think I'm smuggling things but I'm just
drinking water that's that's it
yeah the way I act people usually think
I'm not drinking water either so I feel
you on that you know all right well
we've got a second game
yeah I mean how are you gonna survive
off of that for like the next six hours
what are you gonna do when your glass is
empty Danny I know you're right I'm
gonna go get a huge gallon at the break
so I can compete with you all right
Jenny's back she's got D4 oh my God who
taught her the London what in the world
I I love to see it and you know what her
night she figured it out it's coming
towards the middle of the board not away
so it's an improvement from the last
opening
agreed although I was as painful as it
is to see the London well it's not even
in London anymore
it's good that's good it's not a London
anymore we're not in Kansas anymore
Knight F6 from squeaks all right I got a
feeling he's gonna win this game we're
getting tie break I'm calling it I'm
calling tie breaks oh yeah you want to
put something on the line Maybe yeah
what do you want okay
uh good bet
um I feel like I already owe you a cat
mate a cat made suit I I still haven't
delivered on the couch that was like you
year ago two years ago that was like
that was like last POG Champs actually
okay I had every intention of delivering
and then I just I have your address
um I'm going to Amazon Prime one at
least you know in in spirit of squeaks
and Ludwig energy I would like you know
the cat mates maybe make an appearance
one of these POG Champs if if you send
it if you send it I'll wear it but I'm
not gonna Amazon it myself I shall do it
don't you worry I just got one of those
beautiful botez uh boards by the way
yeah it's amazing it's actually super
nice like I'm a literally inadvertent
merge plug for you thank you it's right
there next thing Carl actually vouches
that that board took him to Grand
Masters so yeah that's the car Nakamura
testimonial standing right next to the
boat I know I'm gonna put a fake quotez
live is my favorite streamer on Twitch
on that wall
take it with the pun she is um this
woman is not afraid of anything you
could say no no she's not she's taking
toward the center which is you know
that's a principal thing to do true so
they do same capture toward the center
King is on um hassled but that's true
we're learning and progressing and Pog
Champs is all about learning
I'm not supposed to reach it okay I
gotta turn this chat over here like this
it's a habit
oh she's changing her chat to emote only
which is good because it's not like her
chat knows anything about Chess they're
literally just spamming gaming
they're spamming they're spamming emotes
and uh
and faces like chow chow want to help
you
toy I think I'm very aggressive
and move this all the way to the night
yeah development is good you know she's
she's moving her pieces forward I won't
complain
and naughty Korean word well she is
trilingual chat you have to flex it okay
let's see what happens not everyone has
a tri-legal chat
it's pretty big Flex I have to say
that's true I did not teach her I
honestly reached out tried to but
woman's busy she's traveling the world
we had no idea she was into chess but
then she was a twitchcon EU and sat down
to play Chess at the chess.com booth and
it was like oh you want to play podcasts
that's how we got Jenny in everything
makes a lot more sense now
she's in Hungary apparently get a bunch
of board streamers in Europe and leave
them with no game IRL except chess and
you'll get everyone to play POG Champs
that's how you do it
uh oh
she backs up the reason that was a
question mark is because she could have
taken the night and taken E5 she missed
that chance so now now her Bishop is in
trouble
well you know Bishop Bishop P3 and it'll
be all good just let's treat the bishop
I'm sure she'll find the square
I was trying to test something here
let's see if I could do the the emote
uh we don't have that I wanted to do a
botez a botez reaction on a square we've
got these emotes we can do come on
someone teach Danny how to use emotes in
chat I believe in you Danny today's
on this platform for a couple years now
today's the day we teach Danny to use
emotes
you know I have to say yes per King wide
open on the line of fire Anything could
happen but squeaks is not castling so
who knows
yeah squeaks though you got it I know I
know we're all rooting for Ginny here
unbiased um but
but I got to give it to squeaks she's
playing in the center he's developing
his pieces he's uh he's on on a good
path and I think Jenny's gonna make the
same mistake she did last time she's not
she's not using her Queen side
I would like to actually I was gonna say
I'd like to see her trade in the center
open up some fouls but I'm worried that
could be even scarier bringing the
Knight but it could be juicy to see
yeah and he needs to put him under some
pressure it's too easy
Chad is also spending good moves King H1
very solid plan for beginners just
moving to safety to avoid any future
chaos
agreed agreed Town highlight town
Let's uh
squeaks let's let's go see what squeaks
is talking about I want to see if he
realizes how good his attack can be
he's just
I just want to know what he's sipping on
it's either serious or apple juice
there's no is it whiskey or is it apple
juice or is it like apple cider vinegar
some people drink that apparently and it
tastes like crap I don't think shimmers
are that health conscious it frees up
the bishop too
attack
but I'm trying to understand what
actually I take it back if I go here she
takes this for free
I need to say oh let's see jerky and
then go behind the scenes and type in
twitch chat let's find out what he's
drinking I'm old Andre I'm like oh I'm
not even not allowed to talk but I'm not
on camera I'm not allowed to talk but
now I'm now I'm now I'm busted
I'm sorry you know what no let Jenny let
Danny lurkin chat I'm so sorry no one
will know Boomer Boomer I'm just sitting
there no don't don't put it on the
screen no one needs to know
oh my gosh he's opening oh it rain and
we also have this
yeah at least look at that that's a good
idea about him though he's all over it
could be another Dark Knight another
player is crazy the first game ever
we've never seen him play Buddies
agree right as well there's a good call
oh wait there we go someone did the
someone brought the emotes up there
someone's doing it someone's putting
emotes on the board no you can't see it
yeah
[Laughter]
I'm about to show you I have like no
idea what Daddy's looking at because I'm
not singing
this is gonna be awesome you're gonna be
you're gonna be so happy when we come
back I don't know I'm really excited to
see these takes I take like a little kid
on Christmas yeah
okay ready ready yes let me see if you
recognize do you know who that is
it's oh you guys finally added me
because it used to only be my sister you
know yeah we wanted yeah
we figured if virtual could learn your
name that we could do it yeah but we can
actually do anything now yeah I know we
can add powerful
wow it's so powerful this is amazing now
you just have to learn how to use them
in chat
and and then you're gonna be the real
gamer here I know then then I'm really
then I'm really gonna do it then I'll be
a happy camper
um and
I would be Starstruck can you add Dorito
on there we're gonna if Dorito sends us
a check we might consider it but you
know okay gotcha
but okay this is awesome we've got all
kinds of stuff here anyway from the
company that uh you know it gets blamed
for making making chess Dumber now we
have emotes on the board there you go
lots of fun for streamers I actually
yeah I discovered this thing called it's
an extension I was surfing the dark web
one day it's called Skin chess have you
ever heard of skin chess I have not and
that sounds like is it like strip poker
no it's it's really not related at all
it just adds a bunch of images to your
pieces and one of them is a ton of faces
streamers
include me and um yeah I'll show you one
day it just makes you okay it gives
skins to chests like you know fortnite
skins
okay yeah but you know it's not his
fault he didn't know about what Skins
are in gaming so I see where the
communication happened yeah I don't even
know what when you say skin chess I'm
like is that like I don't know I mean
like skins for guns but for chess
oh
hey Daddy please wait let's let's go
tune into Jenny's stream she surely sees
the mate this is her moment this is
redemption
come on Jenny come on Jenny
I'm a little alarmed
yeah I'm nervous
okay the queen has there it is
I want to eat this queen so bad
nope there's a mate on the board Jenny
we're not eating anything yet we're
defending
[Music]
uh oh yeah I am I am pretty clueless
Chad is calling me I I have a story to
tell you about how clueless I am that I
almost don't even think is appropriate
for this show let's just say that I did
an appropriate storytelling on stream
I didn't know that defeat I didn't know
that feet obsession is a thing like feed
picks like people are into that okay and
let's just say that I I got
well I don't even know if I should talk
about let's just do anything I have
Brooke I don't know what I wanted I want
to hear more
Danny's feed Storey or Jenny about it
get checkmated we don't want to talk
about that I think my producer just said
Danny wanted to talk about that no you
know things are in handy when his
producer telling them hey buddy no no
no
oh my gosh herself but then it's gonna
she's not gonna get mated because she's
making an intermediate move it's a free
piece no wait yeah it will kill me
I think she freaked out this she didn't
even mean to do it I think she was like
probing like trying to see the legal
squares and then suddenly the night uh
she's saving herself I well this gives
us one more move for her to see the mate
threat she she said Checkmate but I
think she's talking about her own way
and not her opponents but this is good
more time to see it
a bid
this is how you know she's really tilted
when the Korean comes out
yeah
she's speaking in multiple languages
cursing and all of them
is it okay if you curse in a language
that isn't like the main language for
the stream like do they are they cool I
guess no one gives a [__] oh wait I just
said it
I think that's the first time I've ever
cursed on a show before I don't know
what I've done to Danny Chad I'm
corrupted
and it was unhinged oh God we're getting
checkmated she's wondering
is he gonna see it quick
ah no he did but let's go see what he
said
okay oh that's so scary
let's go let's go
thank you
[Laughter]
oh thank you wow well deserved
couple ammo the Dark Horse
well he doesn't know that Ginny is going
to perform some Korean Witchcraft and
curse him out so he doesn't know what's
coming
he does know that he gets a win though
he's 2-0 it's unfortunate for Ginny I'm
not trying to take anything away from
squeaks I like squeaks I think this is
going to be a fun a fun stream to watch
but I'm just upset for Ginny right now
because I feel like she she had she had
some potential there but yeah it's his
first game in the tournament came clean
sweeped he's been preparing for this day
only three days but I'm very excited to
see how far he'll come
yeah and he is a speedrunner so he's
going to get better as he goes let's
take a look at the uh Group C he's now
tied his speedrunner as they say in air
quotes him and Tyler are Titan by the
way that's the matchup later if you
didn't know the schedule these two guys
are going to be playing so that'll
probably decide who's leading the group
two of the greatest speedrunners in
history Tyler ever squeaked I have no
idea two with the greatest speed Runners
of all time and Felix
Felix is probably the best player in
that group by the way I know it's weird
for someone to say that xqc is the best
at anything but he actually is probably
the best player there and that's true
what are the odds that um he's gonna
show up to his match Danny yeah the odds
of him showing up are about as good as
him winning that group so both are like
it could happen very likely I don't know
it's either
and we've got I think that does look
like whiskey
yeah he's taking whiskey Jenny's unhappy
but we're gonna be right back don't go
anywhere secretly got interviews in just
a moment
[Music]
a highlight reel play as sapnap
checkmate's daily dose of internet in a
record six moves what seemed like an
innocent enough opening quickly turned
deadly after a mistimed pawn push sapnap
went for an aggressive early G5 which is
a book move but a bold one and this
gamble paid off immediately when daily
dose responded with H3 which leads to
it's checklist
game two saw a bit more of a fight with
both players in the driver's seat at
some point a hung Bishop allowed daily
dose to get an excellent position oh he
lost it he lost the bishop but it was
not destined to last oh no a free night
ah
saved up a free night and then later a
free rook which was too much for daily
dose to bear and he resigned
move over mittens there's a new Top Dog
in town
Benji the bernadoodle might be an
international master of fetch but chess
lessons with his dad Gotham chess aren't
really sticking
host of his own Public Access TV show
wish boy knows a thing or two about the
most dramatic moment in chess history
a baller through and through buddy
buckets is moving his game from the
basketball court to the chess board
watch out
pinky practices chess from the inside of
his mom's handbag on wolfstock's law
campus don't judge a dog by its Diamante
caller
Pawn chick learned chess from his dad GM
Lavon aronian he has never lost to
another dog at chess and certainly won't
lose to you
this July the possumness is Unleashed on
chess.com
he's I was here I was lost oh okay well
hey hey let's go oh no I think I should
have just dug that sure I got 4K
beat it let's go no 15 unreal no first
try eight in a row nine in a row baby
let's go
let's go let's go I gotta oh cool I got
a little achievement thing I honestly
really enjoyed that that was really cool
become a chess.com Community streamer at
go.chess.com start streaming
questions
let's go
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
yourself
we are back pogtips is back those are
the celebratory moments there from
squeaks and then he takes a celebratory
lap around game review and a celebratory
drink I think a lot of people are
wondering what is in the glass we're
gonna ask him we're gonna ask him right
now
um squeaks what are you drinking man
well I was told to make people think I'm
cooler than I am and say bourbon but
it's actually just unsweetened green tea
I'm a nerd it's literally the secret I
so much respect I feel you and thanks
for saying
oh you got your uh we're gonna say like
you're drinking bourbon meat that's
pretty that's pretty badass you know
just drinking bourbon at 11 A.M on
exactly one day imagine I should have
just watched a bourbon Drinker
yeah dang it no it's perfect
there you go yeah change the story now
on camera everyone believes that the uh
the squeaks you're in POG Champs you're
is it okay if people refer to you as a
speedrunner you're into that right
thank you
[Laughter]
listen I can explain so I called you
speedrunner and then everyone in chat
started laughing hysterically quoting
speedrunner and they started calling you
a slow Runner what do you have to say
for yourself
you know what I think my gameplay speaks
for itself okay I don't think I need to
be held down by the chat the
commentators I am the one that's just
gonna stick behind my chest that was
played today
you know what someone else once said
that right before the greatest cheating
scandal in history
that was that was that was great your
chest speaks
no metal detectors in your room today
but I I'm gonna guess that with game
review you saw you missed a couple
checkmates but you did get the job done
how are you feeling about your chest
right let's turn this into a
professional interview how are you
feeling about your chest and your
chances in POG Champs
well uh listen I'm you know I'm new to
chess I've been playing for now like
three or four days I had a good lesson
with memstar which helped a lot I can I
feel comfortable with everything besides
winning like the last move is always so
hard for me to find so I think I did
pretty well I'm happy with the result
obviously but if I'm to continue on in
this tournament I really start you know
gotta continue grinding you know having
the ability to zoom out and see where I
can check me so overall confident but
still a lot of work to be done
speaking of um professional interviews
did you know that you have 69k
subscribers on YouTube
is that right yes we told everyone to
subscribe to you anymore unless you win
pogchamps then they're allowed true okay
yeah that's fair yeah don't ruin the
funny number that's good that's for sure
well you uh yeah let's keep it there
everyone don't subscribe but you so you
just started playing chess three or four
days ago when lud when lud proposed to
invite you I was like obviously who the
hell is that guy and then secondly
are we are we in drama right now are we
beefing for instance the air quotes but
now you're a new Becca look like me
we're in some drama right now uh daddy
listen I can explain he's new to the
internet he doesn't know how to emote
he's just figuring these things it's
really his first day on Twitch so like
please excuse please excuse Danny he
just doesn't know any better he's new
here no that's fine that's okay is is
Danny Frozen
elaborate bit of all time this would be
an amazing it doesn't be so convincing
if he actually just froze is in person
Danny I'll be there Yoo-hoo daddy you
got this actually hit refresh refresh
I'm not one to talk I literally started
the stream with no audio for the first
30 minutes and was just pretending to
hear things so yeah
well that's fine but uh as as Daddy was
saying so you we have only seen you play
chess for three days leading to this
tournament I saw a clip where you back
ranked Ludwig tell us the real inside
scoop of how much chess history you have
because you seem a little bit better
than I thought
all right so first of all you thought I
was bad that which is fine
you know it's in spirit of the
tournament
true true I mean yeah okay that's fair
but I did play like a long long time ago
when I was a kid and then I did a Brophy
bro versus Ludwig who is super confident
but uh that led to his demise uh you
know classic backlink
Rover's bro always takes out all the the
chess testosterone energy so that's good
everything gets a lot more sense now
that I know it started with bro versus
bro everything makes sense
weird aggression
apparently I should make jokes about
about not knowing who you are because it
breaks the internet and it broke me so I
apologize and now I'm back to say
you know uh
welcome to Pock Champs
so much I really appreciate it it's okay
I'm trying to figure out who I am too
all right well
squeaks I got a feeling we're going to
be seeing a lot more of you man because
you got Tyler today and if you win that
match we'll probably catch up with you
again if you lose we'll probably be like
ah no I'm kidding no we're going to want
to talk to you um and um we wish you the
best of luck seriously I'm I'm a fan and
uh way to go today yeah autograph after
today's stream the moment Ludwig
suggested you the moment Ludwig
suggested you I went like I said I'm
like who is that guy I went to your
channel you were streaming you were
speed running Tetris or something which
was awesome to watch and you weren't
very good at it but it was super
entertaining
I'm a huge Ginny fan
did he just freeze
posting with Danny I finally know what
it feels like when people stream with me
and I love it for once I'm not the
unhinged kid on the internet
like
uh Ed
Daddy
am I the only one carrying this stream
um
guys hear me I love you
okay I love you squeaks I'm sorry man
didn't mean to wait I'm back okay hi
everybody Andrea how'd it go
oh no it went really well and um I think
you know if squeaks wins his match first
Tyler won I think it would only be fair
if you made your Twitter profile photo
squeaks his face
I think you need to show your loyalty
you know I'll forgive the cat maid but I
feel like you need a weird loyalty to
the boys okay all right well I will
figure that out with with squeaks I'll
update my X profile I can't even say x
Elon Musk no one has taken you seriously
but we do need to take this next
interview seriously because Ginny Jenny
is is apparently here
can you hear us
yes yes am I am I am I on the interview
right now
yes you are live Jenny
oh okay
hello how are you feeling Jenny
um I'm okay okay wait a second
Jenny we saw you getting prepped before
today's match you were watching some
chess openings traps videos
very good and serious preparation we
were very impressed
did the the things
but maybe next one yeah no I think it
reminds me of being a student in high
school preparing five minutes before the
test and showing up day love when they
love winning it and at some point the
shot will work I'm sure of it
oh
um yeah I mean uh I hope I had a little
longer time to like practice
but um well I guess I try my best with
the given time
yeah I mean you're practically traveling
the world right now right
traveling the world
yeah you recently celebrated your
birthday happy birthday yes thank you it
was like uh two days ago
cool and you're okay the truth is you
didn't have a lot of time to prepare
you've had a couple of of matches now in
the books that were tough but but
overall are you having a good time and
is it what are your feelings so far
about about playing in this in this
chess tournament
um I think overall failing is like I
it's very it's harder than I thought and
then uh it's just like there are so many
possibilities and there's so many things
that you could do uh that I cannot
really foresee like what's gonna happen
I wish I could play better and then I it
made me kind of want to practice more
and then get better at it but for maybe
next time
I slid in the DMS and I said Jenny do
you want chess lessons
um but I know you're a busy woman so
yeah I mean so past few days since I've
been like really busy because it was my
there's a little bit like yeah there's
because there was a like on my birthday
and everything
how uncool of you
we've also been against you know some of
the greatest speedrunner of History
Tyler won and squeaks so I think just
the odds have been stacked against you
you know but I think after this it's
comeback time
mm-hmm
I don't know
I mean at least I didn't embarrass
myself that much like compared to last
time I was playing against Tyler I was
so tired I think I just like moved from
wherever I think it was better than that
no you I'm so happy with that obviously
yeah obviously squeaks one but no I
think your games your games were good
today you're on the right track I say
you hook up with Andrea right get some
get some chess coaching and uh remember
that there's two brackets right because
there's a championship and a consolation
and and there are there's a final in La
so there's there's plenty of chances
here I just want to say that it's not
over yet
okay it's not over
yeah I'm excited for that I have
tomorrow one more match tomorrow so um I
guess I'll after after this I'll play a
little bit more maybe and then you know
practice just a bit more
all right Jenny well thanks for joining
us it's also it's also late there
wherever you are in Europe I forget but
but uh enjoy your night and we'll we'll
see you later
thank you hi Jenny Bye
I'm so I'm so nervous that my my
internet is about to break at all times
here I'm about to freeze out again
let's just let's just move past that and
I'm not yeah let's let's uh let's talk
about our next matchup because we've got
virtual making his appearance if anyone
follows Anna kramling's stream you see
that she's been working with him right
so he's he's apparently like 1100 Plus
at rapid so I think that uh the sapnap
you know faithful are about to be uh be
brought into a world of hurt I'm sorry
the sapnap faithful don't hate me and
block me on Twitter or whatever the
stuff is you guys do but you know you
don't want to mess with the Snapchat
is my student and he is going up against
an extremely strong player but my
prediction is that if the strong player
plays the cows sapnap can take the win
okay well let's meet this strong player
uh said person virtual I don't think I
know anyone's real name in this entire
event besides Felix I I honestly so
we're just gonna call everyone virtual
virtual is uh one of YouTube's largest
track Mania content creators I don't
even know what that means I honestly
don't know either okay but he is taking
lessons with Anna kramling and he is
legit into chess so uh if you if you're
wondering you know pop Champs 5 is still
young Andre I think we're learning
everybody and we're kind of getting a
feel for who's good this is a guy who
who I think is going to be there at the
end he's 12 29 at rapid yeah I know he's
he's Norwegian so he's going to be
channeling Magnus energy I think he's
gonna be a real chat he's gonna take
today very seriously he's gonna show up
and he's gonna impress us all
I think being Norwegian is an unfair
Advantage when it comes to chess we
should talk about that but let's
we'll get back so intimidating you know
he doesn't even need to show his face
it's just that Norwegian energy you can
almost feel it through the camera yeah I
I sometimes just you know I just
sometimes just try to get magnus's fat
head next to me just so I feel back
so I can feel norwegiance no one can see
you I know but I just want a Magnus his
face
how do you know I don't even know if
they can hear us there's virtual should
we talk about sapnap snaps yeah yeah
let's talk about Snapchat
oh he's oh okay oh yeah that's the uh
that's the replay there he is
crushing daily dose can you hear this
because I don't I don't I don't hear
them but I see it I get it again
he did make daily dose and five moves
that I know people right now virtual
seems like the favorite but daily dose
is a strong player okay he is a five
head and sapnap won that game
I agree and also look at that third
bullet point he's played more than 2 000
games I doubt many of the other players
in the event can hold a candle to that
so I'm gonna say that obviously while
virtual is rated 1200 plus I agree with
you not just being biased to the bow
test student I think sapnap is much
better than his 800 rating especially
when he puts it together and what is the
deal with that outfit like is he trained
conducting
I like it when you roast them so I don't
have to
just don't even know what he's doing
he's doing with that app
ease dressed him or something
but sapnap did win our my sister and I
is blockchamps tournament with that's
right it was a pretty strong lineup so
that don't sleep on snap peas one chess
tournaments before maybe he's gonna be a
double Champion oh what are we doing
that again blockchains or are we allowed
to talk about other events that we're
trying to organize we probably shouldn't
talk about that yet yeah um yeah and I
have no idea so okay but look you know
Minecraft is a game that Denny knows and
not track Mania so let's go sapnap just
kidding
here we go we got virtual he's uh
feeling it doing a little head Bob he's
he's Norwegian so am I I'm also
Norwegian today yeah so I guess in this
layout you kind of have to root for
virtual and I root for sapna okay that's
fine how the sides have decided or if he
loses I'll go get angry Magnus I have
Angry Magnus over in the corner
but okay okay here we go I can play this
he's not playing the cow I slandered it
so much
responded he was saying I will play the
game I feel it here though
now if Chuck I develop
if you text me I develop openings here
if he doesn't I will push the pawn
okay he goes back I think there's gonna
be some real Justice
not that we actually came here to do
that but this is these are some good
players
position
yep
sapnap taking a sip of Gatorade not a
sponsor of this show
um or bourbon who knows or or whatever
is in there
um
all right well we got a big Center sap
not playing fast you got to give him
that right even though he's in a little
bit of trouble yeah he should actually
slowed down and take his time I tell him
many times but he never ever listens to
me and he's impatient just like me
you hear that you hear that this
afternoon because that would be cheating
yeah that's true
maybe you can go secretly type in his
chat too
this isn't a good move but I don't think
it's as bad as the computer says because
if D6 is played the Knight is actually
fine
he was doing he last match sapnap
prepped with Gotham chess had like
Flawless openings I don't know what
happened before this game as his coach I
have to say I'm disappointed in this
opening
but he didn't push so yeah he's getting
a chance he can push D6 try to block
that pawn
and he should
yeah agreed to him
can we uh tune in and hear what sapnap's
thinking because I'm very curious what
he would be thinking with this opening
he's probably talking about his his
great coaching from from Gotham chess
yeah lame Gotham it's just is the F
pawns why is everyone pushing the
f-pawns that's just my one wish from all
my students just stop pushing the and I
told him that like 10 times on her
lesson and then he did it right in front
of my face again
all right let's listen in because he's
going at it whatever he's saying it
oh
really ritual
fun
virtual did you blunder upon yourself to
be the god of the group Andrea it is
buzzing around my face
can we get a poll going
it landed on my laptop here where the
chat is hold on that's dangerous Mike
discovered how to emote if he
all right look at you all saying yeah
let's [__] go we need to let's
[__] go emote do we have this you're
not supposed to read the chat buddy
not helping him because he pushes F on
I think his his fans are just like he
could lose both games and they'll
they'll be convinced that he won you
know the sapnap faithful I've learned
are Danny you're walking stretch guys
please be nice he's new to the internet
oh okay
whispering
they can't hear us that way Daddy I can
just take this Pawn
and secure
okay this is
like virtual really taking his time
and I take
no I kind of like that I don't even know
what's going on I like that maybe not
like the best all right stab them needs
to Castle he needs to move that g night
he used to get that King somewhere
literally wide open and he's opening the
like I taught him so many principles
just for him to do this but we did so I
have spent probably invested the most
hours hold on here you go that's now you
can be proud look at this move D5 okay
he did D5 is a great five is good E5 is
good yes that's annoying I'm just a
little worried about it a little just a
little
yeah
pushes the pun
he like ruined my castle or something
is he sick he sounds a little stuffed up
in the nose
[Laughter]
does he always sound a little Kermit the
froggish
got it everyone needs a gaming voice
like when you commentate chess we expect
you to sound different you know just how
a Hans turned European
and he needs to stop slandering now I
have to say like going from commentary
with Gotham chess to commentary with
Dany is like you know when you go
grocery shopping with the cool parent
like my mom would never let me buy any
candy but then my dad would take him to
the store and let me have everything and
I could say and do whatever I wanted and
right now I'm hanging out with a cool
parent so everyone enjoy this like it's
almost so much like I'm becoming more
well-behaved because of this so maybe
this is the only way to to correct me
okay this is getting a little scary
because there are two bite open
diagonals I can make arrows because my
commentator is gone but we have Bishop
A4 check maybe a potential Queen H5
check sapnap can defend he's still here
with his Bishop but it's it's getting a
little dangerous exactly now we're
putting pressure on this file which is
exactly what I said you don't want to
open the file where your king is and I
said that to sapnap
but let's hear sapnap out a little bit
or maybe actual virtual we haven't heard
virtual sorry take it back bring virtual
in the enemy let's it's it's good to
keep your friends close but your enemies
closer
oh
okay now I got you oh God uh okay this
is getting tricky this is getting tricky
there's a couple lines we have a bishop
A4 but then the night blocks but then
The Bishop's getting pinned things are
gonna be hanging then the Knight just
comes attack the bishop if he knows how
to use that Bishop this is very
dangerous for sapna
oh wait I'm back
hello yeah hello you held it down well I
heard I heard I heard that I was the
cool parent the grocery store yeah I'm
also the cool parent at home my my wife
it's a total hard ass but I hope someone
someone is raising the children because
this is not gonna be you
it's so true oh man okay well Knight
d4's played looks like we're cool a
great move yeah virtual is bringing it
yeah so this is getting scary because if
I mean first of all Bishop is under
double attack and if sapnap moves the
bishop then it's opening a pin on the
Knight which means Bishop A4 on the spot
wins the queen I don't know if virtual
is planning this but this is some insane
tactics
Wow Let's go to Virtual great call
Andrea that was a nice tactic there and
looks like he now has he has it if he
sees it
well it's listening to Virtual in a
world
if nice here
no he can't move the Knight
it's pinned I win his Queen
oh god he's a machine bro I win his
Queen shot Norway air
down a pond but so much initiative this
is over I think
[Music]
Norwegian
CE
actually pogjump's all about not
wondering it's not over till it's over
kind of crazy
but his Queen is trapped he will be
losing his Queen here
[Music]
yeah the rest of podcast is in trouble
yeah no this guy that's a very cool move
I played so many games of Chess over the
last days
I haven't found combinations like this
whoa
no no no you're you're still trapped
you're still trapped you're still
trapped
I respect the attempt you're still
trapped Bishop but yeah don't take it
don't take the bishop that was good
focus by him I obviously Queen takes H5
was you know a million it doesn't matter
but yeah yeah
well sapnap tried a Desperado attack he
tried to save himself
um but it's literally game over
like this was insane
I love doing things like this king is
dead boom ready and it has no mercy from
my poor student is gone
you know all my students watch over the
VOD and they like study it very religion
and there's just gonna be Danny flexing
on them
I don't know what's wrong with me today
I feel like I feel like being on the
show with you I just felt like I needed
to be the one who really like crossed
all the lines I'm trying I've been so
behaved for once Andrea your student did
so good I take no responsibility for
this okay he did one lesson with Gotham
chess and look what happened well my
coaching out the window
talking with him later we're gonna talk
to Levy hey Levy you got to work on that
how to win a chess book buddy shout out
to that all right
um look at this
I don't know what's going on I need
someone else to come here I'll I'll find
a different Fathead
um
yes in trouble
let's just take it but this but this
literally why you don't push the epon
because King got stuck
to the principles that we learned
developed and castled this wouldn't have
happened but he managed the one way to
tie his King up in the middle of the
board and then lose his Queen
by the way Chad just roasted Levy Levy's
one of the only people on the planet
who's written more books than he's read
that was hilarious
wait till I write a book I will
I'm working on actually it's going to be
wild
um people want to know all the behind
the scenes stuff so seriously I am
actually it's coming writing a memoir
let's go I am I am and people are going
to be like oh my Geezer snaps if that's
the thing they say do people say oh much
easier snaps homogeneous you can ask all
the cool kids in chat that's exactly
what we say yeah no you're doing really
well
um we should tune into the machine
ritual yeah let's see what he's doing
I'm just gonna destroy but um I want to
see what he's thinking let's do it
Maps
then I couldn't play this move
one chess lesson and you're gonna win
every game
what about Checkmate I have a I have a
flipping Queen okay by the way can we
call out the background because that's
the last scene before Bambi got shot
what is going on with the song no
I that's awfully here Danny maybe I
thought I I don't know I'm I'm happy
playing questions
better
I did I did a I did an interview on the
street in Norway and everyone was so
nice
to meet interview in L.A yeah in LA and
New York people are verbally abusing me
and everybody was nice and I'm like what
is wrong with you
by the way virtual just crushing it here
Norwegian Style
yeah this is honestly very scary like
I've I thought the other day we were
watching some of our strongest
competitors but virtual so far is taking
the cake
I can't even gonna win this virtual is
going to win this breaking news
who thinks he's the best chess player on
the planet by the way how it's funny his
disconnect between like how hard chess
is and how good he thinks he is is going
to be some of the best content in this
event for sure so shout out to you he
did challenge
um Levy and I quote Hikaru to a chess
match for a thousand dollars ten
thousand dollars actually in his last
stream so you know maybe someone should
take him up on that offer I'm not trying
to call him out on that but we'll we'll
host it let's go I mean again
I don't think he wants to play with you
anymore after he usually what he said
yeah well no one is your rating in chess
actually
I wonder if I could take you it's about
what is it about me that everybody just
thinks I'm bad at everything I don't
know what that is I'm a very good chess
player I'm not saying that you're bad
you know being my level doesn't make you
bad you couldn't be very Advanced then I
could still beat you obviously I we
would probably have an adopt an adopt
Andrea's show if me and you played I I
think you'd be I think I would we should
put that we'll put that to the test
we'll see if I can start to know your
level Danny because every time I come
and take chess with you you're never
commenting on the chest right but I like
it that way so I don't mind he's an
international Master ah don't worry
we're training for him we'll get him
entitled Tuesday chat
I I would love nothing more let's get a
poll going if title players are okay
with you playing title Tuesday it's
happening no no that they hate me enough
it's okay
all right we're just always dominating
this there's not really much to say the
bottom line is sapnap is is getting
snapped oh my God look at that I did it
that was a good one
a sap nap is getting snapped no does
that work it does it just it hurts like
I'm
I'm Crafters like you know I have a lot
of reasons to roast them all the lover
host history but it hurts watching Danny
do it my poor student getting slandered
on both ends now I feel like I need to
stand up for sapnap
well sapnap is getting snapped I think
it's a good one I don't care if you
agree chat
um
and uh unless he orchestrates a
stalemate which but by the way maybe
that's what he's thinking I think sapnap
is uh he's a veteran he's not going to
resign he's going to try to get
stalemate
oh wow Pawn takes F5 just hitting that
Bishop look I think this was a very
difficult step um opening for sapna
because I don't know what he was doing
but the next one is prep will be much
cleaner
look at this though he's going for
stalemate again I respect it
right I'll believe in it but I respect
it
you know well virtual didn't take that
pawn so this is the closest he can get
he's trying you know zapdam knows what
he's doing at least he's gonna try to
sack that book then we just have to get
rid of the G7 square but there's no way
worship is going to let this happen
yep
although I want to point out some
if the bishop comes to D4 Andrea taking
G7 or if anybody accidentally goes to
the seventh rank
right so if he if he if he figures out
the uh
The Rook idea then maybe
he'll yeah he's wrong I mean he's trying
his best all you can do is stall and go
back and forth with his King actually
trying to provoke the bishop to check
him and he can run into six yeah and
they get a compliment from Daddy this is
the first one of the day look at this oh
look at this is genius he's
baiting him oh my God who has to go back
to H6 and then Stack The Rook on G1 but
that just means white has to play a
passive move dude oh my Sab nap is
orchestrating this oh my God okay turn
it on
sad this is his moment yes I'm so proud
I did my student let's go oh let's go
let's see if he sees it I think he can
give up the rook and it's still right
Denny
Danny he moved the road yeah you can't
the wrong Square bro I'm gonna go here
people are praising you or your Genius
[__] he literally a rookie one force
they'll make
they'll make oh now it's too late bro oh
man what's funny is
it probably would have been a draw even
if it wasn't still me but it doesn't
matter now
oh let's not give up hope come on snap
it up all hope I don't even want to
watch anymore I've literally given up
all hope
I'm gonna dude okay
uh no Queen takes Queen takes unpins the
bishop and it's not stupid
but maybe Marshall doesn't know maybe
Marshall won't take might not know
let's listen to Virtual because I think
he might be on the onto the uh the game
he's thinking about it give him a square
oh yeah that is tricky
tricky to see but I saw it I realized
the pin's still there
um now that the Bishops I'll do this
which gives his light Square Bishop time
to move and attack his rook and I'm
gonna push the other Pawn
it's mostly the king that was the
problem here the King was a big problem
what's funny is he has like Peyton one
with Queen f8 I don't think he's gonna
see it there's just like Jacqueline
maybe I'll just play this
I might just play this and just
sacrifice The Rook to simplify things
well this is pitting the bishop so now
he needs to bring the same Strat he
needs to keep the Rook on the board
trying the same problem never mind no
it's not
because this King can go here
his King can go to the square if I take
yeah he sees it okay
that was like there that's his only
language right like I wasn't yeah okay
okay
you're always gonna have two squares
three and it wasn't you're always gonna
have two squares
oh my God that's nasty yeah if you want
you can show it on the board yeah we all
know how this game's gonna go all right
I got baited
he sees the mate we're gonna go to that
why complicated game over
holy [__] it's okay oh that is relieving
I thought I I saw this day the stalemate
I really saw him stay on it and I was
like uh oh this could be bad
but we are in 1-0 the first game we are
in
yeah you got to give him credit even
though it wasn't the cleanest of chess
games that have ever happened in history
he does get the dub Andrea and he did
see the stalemate so even though it was
your student who went down virtual
showing he's uh I mean not the cleanest
of games I actually think this is the
cleanest win I have seen in bog Jams he
literally won that Queen within like 15
moves and was just destroying sapnap
straight out of the opening yeah it was
insane well okay you're right let's
actually show the uh the stalemate
because that was really really fun so in
this position black is stalemated
but the problem is on Rook G1 instead of
what he did
instead of uh moving The Rook over he
could have played check and of course if
white takes it it's a draw oh the rook's
no longer on D7 oh wait wait yeah let's
work on D7 sorry yeah I was right here
black could have played what she won
I got this and if takes it's a draw but
if the king moves up this was the
problem is that it actually that's black
and move like forcing my kid to do their
chess homework like that in the most
monotone voice
and then he gives check and then you get
shot and that's it so okay heads up to
sapnap like you gotta give him a shout
out that he saw there was a chance for
stalemate and he set up this whole thing
where he was frozen and then he misses
one only chance to try it no no heads up
stop nap I'm disappointed in you and
you're in trouble
anyway he could have done it he could
have done it and then if it if it would
have happened it would have made wait
hold on I got a big moment coming that
people and would have made Andrea happy
good one yay okay that was really cool
daddy all right you know it would have
been cooler if it wasn't the first time
I was laughing it was really really cool
thanks yeah but instead it doesn't
happen and instead maybe wait I have a
question in his next game are you able
to like force my face on his chessboard
just to remind him that just like Hikaru
I'm also watching that's that's a really
good idea can we get a feature request
on that we're like maybe I'll just
famine his chat in a few in between the
break don't worry I'll I'll do some
typing that would be that would be like
a good Easter egg for like the whole
site like just randomly Andrea botez's
face just appears on board and you never
know you sent him a cut out I'm gonna
just tell him I'm watching and I'm not
impressed so far all right but okay hold
on I know you're not impressed with
sapnap but we are impressed with virtual
as much as you know just reminds us that
Norwegians are better than us he's he's
better he's better than the average
player in POG Champs
yeah no that was honestly terrifying
that was his first game in the
tournament
um and he's kind of the strongest player
that I like I think the closest matchup
for him is Sea Dog from day one who is
also around 1100 himself so that's
probably the best closest matchup for
him no I agree
all right well sapnap is going to get
some prep we're going to the bathroom or
doing whatever he does in between games
but virtual is grinding oh he's so smart
he's on it no better than us in so many
ways
wait he actually met Magnus in person we
saw it okay wow yeah he must have every
Norwegian also knows each other true
they've all met Magnus in person I'm
nervous but that was a clean game
that was a clean game it was a very
clean game honestly nervous but now I
feel proud is he listening into us he
can't hear us so we can say whatever we
want right normally yeah everything on
the internet
you can delete anything
um yeah yeah that's what I tell myself
too because I I recognize myself when
I'm behind in games it went to the same
school
it's crazy I've actually heard stories
of that school it's like the most news
it's like a sports pool like they went
there and like practically were just on
chess and got a major in chess so it
makes a lot of sense that he went to the
same school as Magnus Carlson
well now I'm less impressed because
Magnus is you know like 2 900 and he's
not so well I'm not saying that um
Marshall will study Chess at that school
but in Norway if you want to you can
and you can practically make it like
your main subject which isn't I feel
like we're just like making up things
about Norway now like did you know he he
told me this he went to this school I
have heard the stories
No One Believes anything Hammer says
anymore Hammer Hammer
my chance it's just baloney but I'm
telling you it's true any Norwegians and
chat someone please tell me I'm not
crazy yeah let's confirm this let's
confirm this
if there's a Norway school where like
they it feels like sports school it's
true
take that Danny okay is it like the
Umbrella Academy kind of thing
um the uh where they take Witchcraft and
Wizardry kids that's the Umbrella
Academy right that was my school
okay yeah
um
anyway so here we are at pogchamps shout
out to Hikaru who's with us and virtual
is gonna be the best player Tyler is
gonna be nervous in this group which is
great
um yeah so who is left in this group to
Play Each Other Well virtual is going to
play ghastly tomorrow which let me say
that is my student and I'm gonna prepare
him to take down the Norwegians all
right I'm told we need to take a quick
break here because the players are uh
are struggling to get organized so don't
go anywhere or grab a snack now's your
time to go somewhere and uh we'll be
right back with the second game between
sapnap and virtual
why
here we go
[Music]
foreign
hi everybody we're back with POG Champs
five hey Kara Nakamura is with us and
what do you have to say Hikaru
grow the game
okay that was the only kind of code I
can think I really searched my rate for
that one
I was the only one
Andrea your student sapnap got snapped
against virtual and I had a badass joke
I'm the little in his chat
I went in there a little bit I told him
to get it together
we need to take down the Norwegian and
um then he said I said don't I said play
real openings he said I don't know any
openings you only taught me the London I
said even the London's better than what
you're doing here we go
let's see just don't just don't push
that far okay
lazy four not bad oh so we need to play
real openings versus I have a machine
you can't take risk here he's gonna do
something true that would have been a
better quote
openings
and um this is a very legit opening so
he does no openings I just don't know
why we're going astray but it's good the
students back on his games
versus the world well singing 21 Savage
but I'm sure he's very focused
exactly that was I didn't even know who
that was that's I was just
whatever that song is
yeah he's like a really big musician
he plays a lot of instruments too
21 Savage
yeah and he he actually is like the top
country music singer right now okay yeah
yeah you should listen to him you like
country
uh not really although I grew up on like
you know like 90s countries so like old
country you know like going straight
Clint Black a lot of people say 21
Savage sounds just like George Strait I
think you'd like him
I know when I'm being trolled okay
Andrea votes
anyway stepdad's developing I'm I'm a
happy woman okay yeah he is this is wait
okay good news there's no way sap okay
can lose this game as quickly as the
last one and now you can be better with
D5 just take he's got a pawn this is
good and he literally pointed this out
earlier in the game and he's got it see
this is what happens this is I had to go
in there tell him to play real chess and
now let's just not give our Queen in the
next 10 moves and this is it we couldn't
hear him but I loved virtual's pause
there he was talking and then he was
like he had like an o
and not a real human being he just he
kind of lagged out for a second now we
know he's a bot
Norwegian Bots a lot you know that half
the population in Norway are actually
just Bots they're just robots
that's actually confirmed yeah I mean
aren't we all
I don't know what I don't know what
let's go can we just get like a mixtape
between sapnap and virtual I just want
to listen into them right now because
they're both going at it let's do it you
choose your flavor let's go let's go to
their world yeah go crazy
very focused student here
I said Spam Jam is yammy's gone or
something and I'm glad he's taking this
yeah just like done very seriously
yeah virtuals
a bad move excuse me
um I don't even know what to do I think
I'm I think he's lost a pawn and if he
takes this he loses a piece so he's not
gonna do that now maybe oh no he has to
move this Knight where does he move it
this is crazy
this is a winning position how do I he's
calculating it right he pointed out that
the Knight closes
if the Knight moves we'll see if he can
find this check and then even this guy
could be hanging holy [__] wait here I
take this pawn and it defends the Knight
still nice he's realizing that right
attacking the defender of the E5 on
okay here
here
he's not here
here oh that works too I mean it's fine
we survived that easily there's better
but
um
come back
wow virtual keeping the pressure with a
counter attack
oh
it's not so good if he takes it though
you can just take the Knight
and then and then if you take this
Knight the queen takes and it's just
money
there we go I can't draw I can't draw
very good today I went to the school for
kids who don't draw good there we go oh
we got analysis I missed a lot of school
you'll read about it in my Memoir
um
back to the Memoir yeah stamina just
needs to not get afraid of ghost threats
here yeah just take it
can we keep their audio running in the
back feels like we're all hanging out as
a big fat happy family
I want to see what virtual is thinking
about honestly when we can because he's
uh he's the one who's got himself in
trouble
by the way we're getting this position
on the board as long as sapnap comes
with the queen oh wow oh snap
let's go coming back hopefully take us
into tie Breakers
virtual's in trouble just like that turn
of the turn of the what is it flip to
the script well there's one thing you
gotta prioritize here before yeah not
not my generation
oh no
but so this still this it threatens mine
Anything Could Happen not gonna
celebrate too early yep
if I don't not Overkill the fat lady
sings Have you ever heard that or is
that yeah I have heard that I never
understood that one they're like why
it's iffy I have to go through with it
right I think it has to do with like the
Opera or something I don't know this I
actually I actually have no idea where
that
yeah you're right Opera Opera done here
we're here to block the chat uh Castle
If he if he allows white to take the
pawn on B7 I think I might have to do
that and I have to play faster okay take
you end up in this really iffy
oh you can get pinned here no you cannot
if you listen closely
you're flying into my position
she is I think live reacting to his game
as well maybe it is anyways both coaches
are watching let the better student wins
okay okay
and he did it quick I honestly think me
threatening him very seriously in the
chat made him wake up
yeah and the chat is now spamming the
bow tennis I gotta say you literally
look like the character from like a
Megan doll horror movie in that picture
like in a sequel for that creepy movie
that picture of you is one of the
creepiest things I've ever seen I
thought it was a lovely picture I
thought I looked great in that picture
you don't like being compared to Megan
the evil the evil bot dog I thought it's
a nice friendly picture like it's fun
and Mimi you know like yeah like haha
I'm smiling it might be so funny and
quirky do we have any Danny modes can we
see I'm not that is not that is not a
face that I would be excited I don't
know that just it scares me it's like
seeing a smiling child
well that's practically what I am but so
are you oh we got Danny with the shades
nice yeah I've got it I don't even
remember when that happened there's a
little twerky mode I do that from time
to time on camera
oh yeah
all right well dude stab naps
look at this like actually so
it's playing great
he's up a couple of Pawns his King is
safe he's doing good keep developing
doesn't even need a trade yet
bring out that dark squared Bishop
activate the Rook Rook this is what we
have been training for sapnap
all you gotta do play in the center you
know get your pieces out like Andrea
said I don't know why we're talking like
this he can't hear us but you know
um
if he doesn't get the pieces out though
remember virtual is higher rated for a
reason as much as you don't want to hear
it Andrea I mean you got it he's much
much better than us absolutely he has a
juicy 1200 rating like that is very
intimidating
you think sapnap is intimidated by the
rating you think he thinks about it oh
look honestly even look
yeah let's uh let's bring sabnab's audio
in or just tune in to sapnap
honestly I think he's I think he's not
going to throw this game push this Pawn
I think that's the play
because luckily if he tries to do
something like learning how to drive
plan
yeah which is good I like to draw
diagonals too like this I like that he's
just trying to keep this is exactly what
I'm saying this is my
geez
I haven't been able to post anything
from pop Champs
oh man okay Queen D6 is played that's no
good what is that but we'll see if
sapnap sees it the reason is
if the bishop comes out to attack the
queen if that dark Square Bishop comes
out to F4 black is in big trouble
when I get excited it gets dangerous so
I will space them yeah we all finally
oh he played it before
because he can't he can you see if the
queen takes the pawn on C6 Knight takes
C7 is a four and that's a that's a
forking problem effing good one effing
effing short balls
yeah we don't curse on here because
children watch this channel that's right
I already accidentally set a curse word
for the first I remember the most the
most surprising curse word that I ever
heard was from the mouth of Anna Rudolph
because you just don't think she like
even thinks of curse words she just
seems like so sweet
and it just shocked me when she cursed
during POG Champs like looted it must
it's that effect that you have on people
Danny yeah
look at this this is by the way children
by the way I have four kids yeah I have
a 17 year old
a 15 year old an 11 year old and a
seven-year-old I know did they ever
watch your streams that are just like
embarrassed all the time all the time
yeah honestly that's good good that
makes you happy
yeah like I kind of grew up with a dad
like he wasn't streaming on Twitch but
he was a chess t-shirt always come to
school he'd always like come to all my
chess tournaments and like talk to all
the chess kids so I just want other kids
to grow up with the same dad energy
although now it's hard for them because
all their friends are super into chess
so they're like I hate you bad but also
my friends think you're cool
that's so sweet oh man fluid look at
this Andre if he had played B4 it's it's
Rover because if Queen takes we got an
effing problem and if Queen here the
Queen's getting into into I think put it
like that Jesus wow honestly yeah a
tricky move to see but if this was given
to him on a puzzle rush I bet he'd see
it but it's hard to think of those moves
but if he was like fully focused I think
he would but sevenf seems pretty focused
I don't know
yeah let's let his audio play
yeah let's let's see what he's thinking
about
Queen incoming uh not really well I
guess that was earlier it's not possible
anymore now let me see this funny versus
Bishop yeah that's a great move C3 yeah
I mean how does he defend that upon I
don't even understand
I think we should do this
you know he didn't see the tactic he's
seeing all the threats because I don't
want him his Bishop yes sir I just
subscribe
but I still I still have I'm defending
this second account in this year the
only other subscribers
are my my uh
you can't push it you can't push the
pawn
queen takes the bishop which I'm I'm
fine with him moving his Queen back
because then I can I can just March
these pawns up I think like next move
like I'll do something like if he moves
he's playing fantastic hear this pawn
and then like just slowly but surely I
mean I just have plus two materials
yeah he's got a three minute time
Advantage which is also a big thing to
notice
getting a little tricky
nice push up on SpaghettiOs don't do
that don't do that you
don't think here
I push the button and he takes
uh-oh
uh oh
doesn't see it please I've been praising
you all day and I would like to have one
of my students bring home a win
why are you thinking this is a critical
position
I kind of want to hear him saying why
are you clicking randomly I don't know
why I'm worried I'm like so scared about
this move for some reason I think we
just go back and oh thank God are we
gonna stand sapnap I bet that's a sapnap
fan a snapper as they're called I think
they call themselves snappers
have no idea what you're saying anymore
what are the side not faithful call
themselves
right logic fans call themselves the
rappers The Rat Pack and then there's I
think that's gonna go back he pushes
back he pushes this and I push that okay
I go back he pushes this I push this and
we should okay by the way he played a
good move shout out to the Snappers out
there snappers
we like to call ourselves the tools the
tools
exactly right uh
it's true
all the pressure I'm putting out of is
working yeah I think it's totally you I
think
Daniel
virtual is uh in a bit of trouble but
we'll see if he can get himself out of
it with his adorable Norwegian accent
let's go tune in to where Bambi to where
Bambi was last seen wait does Bambi die
in the movie or does Bambi's mom die I
forget
okay
daddy almost a pawn here though how am I
ever gonna win
okay I mean it's not Unthinkable I win
it after the queen trade actually
yeah so here wait it is Unthinkable take
this that's so messed up this
threatening the rook and then this and
there's the double attack
wow look at this guy oh gosh look at
this guy okay the games yeah this is a
very high level
this is real calculation somebody stop
it now
I should be winning
Magnus in his ear
and this is his most dangerous Pawn so
this gives me some time I know actually
he found like yeah
wow I think this is good I still very
nervous for sapna you should be you
should be because now virtual's finding
his feet because he really just got in
trouble with the battle
but it's like a weird Snappy should do
is put the bishop and attacked that Rook
on f8 and then you can save the pawn
oh man that is a beautiful move
but not easy there's a fun line that
goes okay he didn't play it but I'm
gonna quickly show it on a real quick
analysis board if he had played here The
Rook would have gone here but then you
can go here because on the trade you
actually win the F7 plane at the end of
the line
Danny is an international Master after
all he does know how to play every once
in a while I black out everyone's when I
black out and do some chess commentary
foreign
that would have been good but now now
instead virtual wins back upon and we
have a
we have a thriller ladies and gentlemen
but let's be honest we're all
collectively rooting for the Snappers
out there because we want tie breaks we
want free chess yes yes well except for
like the five Norwegians in chat okay
I've seen them in there and they're very
proud yeah
yeah and and Hikaru I feel like Hikaru
is rooting for for the Norwegians too
don't forget about it he's part of this
conversation at all times what do you
think cargo's coffee is right let's
guess what has he taking that well
coffee cup man doesn't he's one of those
psychos that doesn't like coffee
pure water
that's my guess off of pure pure tactics
puzzles
he just does one puzzle rush and he
wakes up right away
but yeah I was gonna say
show us yeah
we should go tune into virtual because
if he finds this we've got problems in
the in the in the sapling world
virtuals move will he see the check on
G6 find out what's important on podcast
five
can you go to the corner
oh I sees it stop tingles back it's a
little oh we didn't get a chance
man this looks good check here King goes
into the corner he's very good
I don't know a blood wig is to wait for
anything that goes forward
but what's funny is if uh
as if Danny wrenches
[Music]
third account that's the difference okay
if if it's still enough if sapnap cease
to run the king to the center he's
actually still okay Andre you got to
play King of lucky for him it's forced
now he's not over yet oh my God I mean
these really only equalized but like
virtual's calculation is very impressive
and I have to give credit words too yep
yep does this check do anything it
protects my Bishop
the background incredibly strong not
gonna lie they're talking about me
obviously yep you are a tool after all
yep okay the uh oh yes I killed the
fruit fly
it looks like you didn't do anything and
no one can see you
like that was so dramatic there's no
lighting goes bad you can't see it yeah
I'm sure you killed the fruit fly Danny
I I totally believe you that you
defeated the fruit fly
[Laughter]
you have no idea the torture I've been
going through this entire show with this
freaking fly now I killed it if you're a
real tool you would eat it just take
please don't eat it don't eat it don't
eat it
like if I I pressure Denny hard enough
he might actually
you look at your student Rook G3 what a
baller move that's it
yeah this is this is beautiful
I believe it's right I'm very wow wait
is this like actually nearly winning but
I mean it's gonna be a huge yeah this is
look at that eval bar shooting up oh
yeah because after they he'll win the F7
pawn and now he's left oh my God this is
game okay bring in some stab now audio
as well but this is beautiful
this is you just I'm sure he sees it
this was all part of his plan but wow I
think also when you're playing against
someone who's doing such high level
chess it forces you to ascend as well
I wouldn't know but it was a second fly
and I killed it too oh God
how where's there not one but two like I
don't believe you all right here we go
snap now
he has to move this guy
can I get a free piece he's a killer
silent killer different types
wow he's seeing it and then he has hard
on F7 hanging forty seven seconds yes
under a minute this is your game Sab nap
this is it I mean there's no I mean if
you guys
wouldn't let Danny go to the bathroom
because he's been in trouble
okay yeah it's a break they couldn't
hear the producers were yelling at me
because I accidentally linked art linked
our our vmix link you know but we fixed
it so don't don't tell people you leaked
oh my God
oh
man
is this just Checkmate right yeah
he's got it if he sees it
sees it can't go here
is checkmate
okay
I get so scared guys I'm like I'm gonna
[__] blunder I know why he shook that
gatorade bottle like that I don't know
what it did to you but
yeah he's got it let's go
oh
save energy just like coach
all right and then that brings the win a
beautiful game I'll let it go in there
it was spam and threaten to him to play
real openings and he did virtual with
some insane gameplay but sadness took
down the 1200 we're going into
tiebreakers this is good
tie breaks tie breaks I also just
realized virtual's in group b so my
whole call out I was setting up virtual
versus Tyler was actually wrong because
they're not even in the same way half
the time we don't know what you're
talking about Danny it's okay yeah I I
don't know either but I do know I'm
supposed to talk about the tie break
rules now because we're going to extra
overtime chess sudden death dodgeball
three minutes plus five seconds per move
everybody white is determined by the
accuracy score of the previous two games
if we're still tied players will swap
colors and we go again repeat the
process rinse and repeat to avoid
dandruff that's it
he's learned so much
I did it that's it we've created a
monster
I'm having a great time
any renters some professional show I've
ever had but are we going we're going
right into tie breaks here
no bathroom break for Dan no
oh 30 seconds no time right nope no
bathroom break for Dan okay darn it
we're just gonna see you get
progressively unhinged as the time goes
on all right well Jokes Aside we had a
lot of fun Andrea but that was a baller
game from sapnap start to finish play
fantastic chess he was shocked that he
had Checkmate on the board but he
ultimately found it and we're uh who so
what is sapnap splits game like you
would know how does he play in faster
time controls
time but
but I'm worried because he automatically
wants to play Everything super duper
fast and sometimes fast does not equal
good
but I don't know how rituals Blitz is
I'm very curious and apparently chatting
for me he is a new account so apparently
it's not 1200 but I mean he's sure
playing like one
well also I think virtual has played
more rapid than blitz so if you talk
about sapnaps you know bullet skills
from blockchains and other of the other
events like and by the way now virtual
is playing a French which is a horrible
opening so you gotta you gotta be
rooting for Snapback I agree with that
my sister also plays the French
yeah the French is the worst
not not done language just the opening
uh don't clip it and try to take me out
of contact
okay
take this out of context he hates the
French you heard it here
all right okay there should be three
played
can we do that mixtape thing again I
would love to I want to hear I want to
hear what Sappy's quiet moment
ready some Italian energy
slander we got
we got it I'm waiting
oh that's not a good move
three oh yeah the check dark it's not
easy to see
he didn't push the F Pawn
um okay yeah the danger could be coming
but this this actually is totally fine
you can push that seep on
if they yeah let's do it let's check out
snap nap here
sappy sappy how are you nappy
[Music]
yeah dino dance
why are we playing a sad song you know
we need a hype song that's it I'm I'm
pulling it out where's the playlist come
on you know I'll just use this where is
it but this is a two minute
max volume max volume
there we go
this is good this is my type of music
[Music]
it's not that'd be nappy anymore looks
like he's waking up
[Music]
audio on I'm calling him sap now my
nickname for him just keep changing
their relationship is progressing
it looks like Danny has adopted another
kid
fabnab was one of his sons
you know I bet my I bet my kids know who
sappy is the snap probably it is
ugly makes them proud
yep awesome good stuff
yeah this feels like the the start
this is like a start to one of those
anime shows that my kids watch it was
like a it's like a like something I
don't know and then someone's about to
go oh like oh like you know how they do
that in anime where it's like everything
is over the top
chat and
[Laughter]
okay
any weebs in chat weebs out
Websters all right so let's talk about
the chests here
we need to get castled if we're a sappy
because virtual's team just got canceled
the one thing I'll say for the for the
napsters is that sapnap seems to handle
himself on the clock better than virtual
yeah I think this is the only game so
far well I mean he had a great opening
but 7Up seems a little bit more like a
favorite now but I'm not sure Anything
could happen but this is definitely
where in sapnap lands now I agree and
remember sapnev got white because he was
the more accurate player wow well that's
actually super impressive yeah he played
the better overall brand of Chess
between those two games so there you go
crazy because he kind of
he hung in there for so long
yep
all right yeah I have to say sapnap
there was like months where he would
only play bullet chess and I told him
it'll never help your chest and you need
to do your puzzles and you know I have
to say I was wrong I'm glad he did all
those months of bullet because they're
paying off now
it's true you got to be handy I'll be
able to hand yourself on the clock and I
cannot stop bobbing my head along with
sapnap it's just this is a this is a
forever
thing now let's tune into virtual as
well I see some yeah some people calling
us biased commentators I hear you we're
not I am we're not biased I have been
biased so let's hear out virtual I think
virtual just came in so strong that we
felt like we had a root for the underdog
but now no one's an underdog here
there he is
what's he gonna say I don't think we
hear him
I think he just hasn't talked no he has
music yeah wow
it up okay there
yeah he's nervous
he's got the classic lip squeeze going
that's where you squeeze your bottom lip
together with your fingers because
you're nervous God I feel so stuck let's
go here I think
I gotta play something like this and get
my Bishop out but if this takes us he's
a counter attack
I really gotta get this diagonal
probably so B B6 I think that's a great
idea actually doesn't hang up on that's
good
get developed
oh that's almost strong
almost it's not strong
here and he has a double attack but I
also have a double defense
is most
practitioner diagonal I wanted
yeah he goes back
now yeah you called it sapnap will
sometimes play Too Fast right that
Knight is a fast move yeah they're kind
of complete opposite yeah blasting his
music build a good position feeling the
confidence but virtual did not let that
get to him he stayed focused and now
he's starting to actually get a pretty
good position
virtual sees it look at that I'm gonna
play here
I'm so nervous that I don't even know
anymore who I'm rooting for Queen takes
Queen takes
because I'm a Norwegian today I'm an
honorary Norwegian today Daddy's just
slipping sides all day long wow a double
a discovery attack here opening the
bishop on the ninth
okay
it can also play this if sappy if sapnap
doesn't I can't even say sapnap I just
have to give him a nickname every time I
refer to him if sapster doesn't say so
he doesn't take he realizes the threat
around him oh my God wait yeah
you're so tunneled and focused in they
forgot about the night
both sides miss the Knight heads up a
chance to defend
both under a minute now virtual has
turned it around on the clock now we're
truly entering Danny land's most
unhinged lands of all
yeah
Denny's now rooting for the Norwegians
therefore rooting for team Norway here
team Norway wow so yeah they both missed
that night but I can tell sapnap is a
little more serious now he started with
a pretty big time Advantage but now he's
actually lower on the clock which he
needed is to take his time there because
he had almost blundered a piece
yeah remember they still have increment
even though it's Blitz and we are in tie
Breakers if you're just joining us where
have you been
thank you for coming finally you're in
trouble
um but we have a great pod Champs
tiebreaker going
yeah it's actually right here Magnus
first Hikaru right now it's like
it's magnets championship
we've got
we've got 26 SEC 25 seconds now for
virtual he is getting down
this is going to come down to just pure
Insanity by the way this is just going
to be a game that both sides blundering
bullet instincts
yepperdoodle scoodle that's also a thing
people still say the upper doodle
scootal that's the thing
need to know how to read to write a book
oh that's so true okay Bishop to C oh
we've got Queens under attack we've got
problems it's a bad move black and take
oh we didn't see it honestly I'm so
blind oh my God he could have taken the
bishop attacking the queen you draw an
arrow you know the show yeah no there it
is I honestly didn't even notice that
either but with with 30 seconds this is
stuff
okay 20 seconds for the uh the the
saplings
Bishop takes snaps it off the board
sapnap Style
episode but virtual is very is actually
performing much better under time
pressure and now sapnap has only 10
seconds he needs to move and there's a
giant weakness on C2 which all of
virtual's pieces are pointing towards
but can he take there'll be a little bit
of a in on the queen yeah dangerous oh
look at that wow that's that's a pin
yeah that's a nice move that's pretty
crazy
he sees the pin it's not threatening
anything yet but if sabnob forgets he
could blend her he said run away from
the pin but now there's there's hanging
pieces there's a Pawn on C2
nice hanging nope no one wants anybody
no there's more Knights hanging I don't
know what's hanging anymore something's
hanging dude oh my God
flip-flopping just like Danny on which
side he should root for
you know what the uh I'm I'm all in on
team virtual here now that sapnap is
under 10 seconds I'm I'm front running
I'm rooting for the uh he's got a huge
time bonus here
oh but sapnap sees the fork look at
sapnap oh my God oh my God that's huge
that's good exactly I didn't even say
the fork my students playing better than
me this is great Wow Let's go check
let's check out sapnap he just found the
fork I think he's got it
and the saplings around the world
no back rank mates that's all we need to
be careful because if he no wait never
mind I'm rooting for white I forgot yeah
well still dangerous
oh he's got it he sees the fork double
question mark any actually
oh he sees it made
wait let's check what checkmate
go
yes
honestly I feel that oh my [__] god
wow oh my God I knew people oh that's
weird I was gonna check meet him oh my
[__] kind of crazy I I did not think
that mate was gonna happen
dude
wow
such a strong player and has played
amazing games snapped up a little bit of
a faster player and and virtual was
putting on the pressure he has great
positional chest he was developing those
pieces he was coming back and then just
one teeny tiny Fork under time pressure
and the game was over
nobody sapnap I mean you called it like
he wants to win this he wanted it he was
actually kind of a a late invite but
sapnap is here to win that up
but I have to say you guys really
humbled him because he was like yeah
they wouldn't let me in at first but I'm
glad I've got a spot well we didn't let
him in because he had already played
pogchamps for and we're like you know
you've already had a chance and so
that's fair I mean I'll just tell him
tell him straight up to his face like he
wasn't on the top of our list
I blame money
if people were calling us biased
commentators this is good A little bit
of controversy no I'm I was I'm all team
virtual I think virtual you know his his
chances are still are still gonna be
here but this is can we just call out
this group for a second because Group B
is turning out to be like the strongest
group actually yeah yeah
once again half of my students
coincidence I think not all the saplings
all the saplings just became real real
real toads is that what happens I don't
I like what happens to tadpoles when
they swim they become ah ah yes I'm
losing it I'm losing it I was trying to
think of a the saplings I'm graduated
well okay I mean meanwhile the
Norwegians they're also catching up
daily dose like this group is so hard
daily dose himself I'd watch him play
chess very good chess player but it is
like so far the sweatiest group I have
seen
I agree and daily Joe seems to have
gotten the the short end of the stick
right in terms of the group because now
with ghastly grinding sapnap there and
virtual this group b is has got all the
strong players but uh yeah all right if
you're if you're watching this then
you've got all the chances you need to
get a premium membership on chess.com
the twitch drops have been activated
that's right they say Diamonds Are a
chess streamer's best friend and you
don't want to miss your chance the
twitch drops are active for the next two
weeks all you got to do is watch two or
more hours of the chess category on
Twitch and then uh connect your account
via twitch and chess.com it's actually
not that hard to do and then you can
play
these diamonds are actually so valuable
my dad always I feel embarrassed asking
but he'll always message me be like hey
our third cousin in Romania wants a
diamond membership can you get it for
free and then I go and slap I ping the
chest I'm like hey guys and I think I've
hooked up like seven of my cousins with
free chess.com diamond and they're
they're very grateful so perks of being
on the chess.com team but these diamonds
are are very valuable
um so if you guys can also get them for
free right now you know Papa votes as
vouchers for them because I've literally
hooked up my entire family across Europe
now we know why revenue is going down
thanks
use the command Drops Keep the trend
going let's think chess.com together
let's sync chess.com together and get
free Diamond memberships everybody I
love it
no no I'm totally teasing there's sapnap
right there going nuts we're about to
have a break he really came back
yeah virtual is uh stressed don't go
anywhere when we come back we got more
POG Champs five ahead get your BR get
your snacks in now because we'll be back
in a few
because he still has really good chances
what oh no a full blunder
oh my gosh she just resigned Hikaru we
got a resignation it's going to the Thai
brain
take take the pawn oh
yeah the question is does hafu take the
Grand Master approach here and just take
the Perpetual for the championship
doesn't matter
we gotta listen and she's about to
deliver the goods
[Music]
oh my God
holy [__] let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
and faustive wow beats the two pieces
with the Rook Aaron made a huge
investment giving up his Queen for Turks
[Music]
black ones are still quite fast I
literally have no idea what's going on
oh no he's about to lose
fantastic please
foreign
[Music]
what's up
we are back POG Champs 5 continues here
Danny wrench Andrea botes Andrea botes
grand master botes she goes by many
names uh but uh thank you thank you for
the formal introduction you guys have
seen my face for the last three hours
but it's nice to finally be called
Grandmaster votes finally finally making
a title Tuesday appearance near you but
all right Andrea we have two more
matches coming up we're gonna Jump Right
In no more interviews no more wasting
time it is squeaks versus tyler1 I
cannot wait for this this is match we've
been talking about all day long like you
have been very excited for school
tyler1 I have been and and I think it's
it's because the last time Tyler won was
live he you know challenged everybody on
the planet yeah maybe he'll challenge
you too
maybe he'll challenge me too I mean I
just have to but I've been accidentally
roasting people today so I have to be
careful because if I roast him first oh
there he is about to create the mirror
effect be careful what you say he
actually dodged it what'd you say
but again I think Tyler's confidence
they say that happiness is the Delta
between expectations and reality I think
I think Tyler Tyler's chess skills are
somewhere between the Delta of
expectations and reality and I don't
think he's as good as he thinks he is
but I don't think he knows that which
makes him maybe better than he should be
which is great
good for him
yeah no squeakers Tyler I can't tell
who's gonna be the favorite it was our
first time watching squeaks play I I did
watch that game of Eternity Tyler played
the other day which Tyler is a very
aggressive and attacking player he
missed the main one but he was very
strong very strong
Tyler Tyler's a good player no jokes
aside and um
yeah and here we go he's taking on take
on squeaks and the Dorito gang
the Dorito Army
Tyler is 1200. I I think he was like 200
last time I don't know if uh
you know he's been studying or I missed
something but
yeah I have no idea
um
anyway yeah so squeaks is going we've
got E4 on the board we got Doritos in
the emotes
um no real talking from squeaks right
now he's real focused and nervous yeah
chat Ronaldo just broken there's just
actually moment of silence but everyone
moment of silence for POG Champs
remember here everyone come together for
serious chess I Grand Master bow Tes
with Hikaru behind my back most serious
chest Tournament of which of the century
and we're we're gonna about to see
another beautiful game
for those who don't know what pogchamps
is about it's about supporting Hikaru in
the World Cup that's what this show's
about you know
and uh we are here for them we stand by
Hikaru in His World Cup debut uh not
debut his campaign
um
squeaks and Tyler are playing we've got
squeaks here
I'm kind of just repeating myself a
little Captain Obvious yeah
yeah symmetry coming B5 but this is
actually speaking of grand Masters this
is Yuri or I don't know I've only played
the London and I think history you told
me Jenny uh B5 is just put my Bishop
well it's kind of not great but squeaks
doesn't play the aggressive movie and I
think he's thinking about bringing his
Bishop
so maybe one Beyond like here
okay
I mean he's saving the bishop but like I
said Tyler is very attacking very
attacking player
and I can do something like this maybe
yeah
yeah good plan too
I feel like Tyler is uh just he's pumped
up now I think he I think he heard me
kind of calling out that you know that
his uh his expectations are not in line
with reality so I might you know we'll
see what happens there but I'm not gonna
lie to you when you were talking he had
a look on his face and I was I was
scared I I thought we were in big
trouble
we probably are
okay he plays Knight D4 which is moving
a piece twice before you develop meaning
no no you don't want to do that white
can take on E5 here
depending upon
sometimes in these openings you actually
you do Gambit the epon for each other
but the difference is our Knight on C3
is defending the E4 Pawn so let's see if
squeak sees the Free Pawn
yep he's thinking about it
Tyler is uh he's he's got he at least
has a super Grand Master camera position
right you get these Grand Masters all
set up before you do these tournaments
and they're like yeah I'm gonna be here
the whole time and in the moment the
chest starts they go like this and
they're off screen you can die and
you're like bro
yeah all right so squeaks did not take
the Free Pawn you think Tyler a little
bit of a chance to come back putting the
Knight on attack there's really only one
square for the night but it gives a pawn
are they gonna see it this time
it's crazy though because I would
actually say from uh pogchamp's chess
perspective taking this phone is a
really bad idea yeah it opens up the
king completely right actually kind of
terrifying now that I look at it
yes we saw in that game um sapnap versus
virtual what happens when you open the
file on your king So now that I'm
looking at this again we should
absolutely not touch that pawn
it's not worth the danger he has to
sense the danger and he does he does
let's let's check out Tyler and what
he's saying if possible maybe he's um
talking about
his next workout has he ever worn a
non-take top shirt is he ever nothing
I'm actually gonna I've only seen two of
his streams counting this one and last
one he was wearing muscle tees
no he doesn't
oh apparently he only wears muscle tees
okay there you go the thing in the chess
community
forced to wear muscle tees every Grand
Master
I hope that someone clips that you said
that you'd never seen his stream until
recently
you're not the most hardcore gamer but I
have seen his clips
um and they they kind of terrify me
but he's probably a nice lad
and you know I think
I think I I resonate with e-rob you know
the younger sibling so maybe that's why
I stay away from Tyler's stream
yep
e-rob a member uh participant in the
first POG Champs we ever had shout out
to Europe
how did e-rob end up doing
dude uh not too great but um
I don't know I asked
like life or death bro it's a it's a 400
it's a
1000 rated chess game move man
is not happy with the time time control
here but it is a 10 minute game so
there's really no need to rush because
it's actually very important you take
your time nice but respect Heather's
playing well that's what I'm talking
about baby
came to play a little ball
I was enjoying that
yeah me too I don't know why we ever
left
anyways
Tyler is developing and he is gonna
Castle this is this is a good side on
Tyler's chest if it does get canceled
look at that Tyler's uh
he's played some good chess here but so
is squeaks remember squeak learned how
to play chess like four days ago and
he's speed running his way to 354. he
has played chess for a long time but I
actually asked him and I kind of forgot
what his answer was
but pretty sure he's been playing longer
than three days but he only has three
days of chess.com games
got it got it okay there you go
he's already 354 then
is Danny ranked high enough that Tyler
would even challenge him that's a good
question I'm actually not as not not as
good as Hikaru or Magnus so if you want
to challenge me Tyler
um
anyway but we've got squeaks the speed
Runner
versus Tyler the LOL player
oh
hell isn't that what you call it LOL LOL
Tyler
[Applause]
so for all I know it could be what the
what the gamers call it
yeah they do they call it they call it
LOL LOL
they open up his Bishop this is nice
from tither
he's up almost two minutes on the clock
too
it's very solid so don't judge a book by
its cover he's playing very good judge a
book by its cover I admitted and there's
even an open diagonal on the king queen
queen B6 check
I was just gonna highlight that F3 often
a move you wish you could take back
LOL Tyler blows up the position
okay well
you know he's gonna reroute his Bishop
to G7 he wants to do a little fettuccine
I see it
it's actually a really good move
fettuccine alfredo yeah it is lunch time
after all but then again on this bourbon
so if anything he might just right now
like just level up
bourbon will do that levels up your
confidence even if not your gameplay
the uh
although we have had confirmation
apparently it is green tea apple cider
vinegar everyone it is not bourbon just
FYI
squeaks is I don't know where we got the
vinegar from but yeah
it's phenomenal for it look at this
movie should be three defending the
diagonal and developing the pieces
beautiful
some good chess what is going on here
high quality stuff
who is the creepy guy standing behind
Andrea BOCES guys don't talk about it
please uh that is the chat I'm not sure
everyone's behaving okay no funny
business today
he's just he's just there don't ask
all right Tyler wants chatting away
let's listen in he just played this H5
move
I have an idea
okay
be very very quiet I have an idea
oh my God I have an idea what if yeah
guys he has an idea
what could it be oh not that one no well
it's not bad actually two turns so it's
dangerous let's say that I get this Pawn
here
he takes it I take it and opens up this
right here
I somehow move my knight right here and
my queen like night night Queen he
doesn't have a night I would go night
right here right here
this is a learning game guys
okay actually Vlog wow start the process
I'm a little concerned if his opponent
goes F4
but yeah F4 G4 thing's gonna get tricky
oh wow position right away
GG but they're playing they're playing
next they're playing chess yeah
this is actually I mean he has a net on
the board so
playing like 3D chess
yeah I think you and I they're playing
on a on a different level here some
fight because they're because because
obviously squeaks agreed with him that
that was a plan he needed to stop with
G4
which I could have been an Escape Plan
oh
dude what if I stack my Bishop [__] it
yolo I don't care I don't care I'm
trying I am fully committed to this play
I don't care it'll work oh wait never
mind because he moved to spawns okay
never mind I just could ask why why why
why I feel the need to give The Bishop's
very happy really you're just moving one
square you don't have to go all the way
no need to sacrifice him just yet
but he's not afraid of anything and
that's that's good it's a good trade in
a chess player you know it's why I've
hit GM
bring the Rook
good move
and then rookie and
making all the jams proud
okay I don't know what the [__] I don't
know how he went from sacking the bishop
to one of the best moves but I'm not
gonna oh in my head
I seen like a glimpse of
success
yeah me too
and in my head I also see that
I also see you in an Orange Grove okay
take this it's moving identity can this
work though if I okay okay
play The Rook
um however now G5 is a little a little
scary after white takes back
yeah and Black's King is way more open
than whites unless it gives up the G
Pawn so dude
if I get my queen of my Rook on this
like side of the board let's say I go
Castle here
oh the castle probably has to go first
huh
however Rook G8 okay there's no way but
Rook G8 Pawn push King F even that
doesn't Castle it's very hard to defend
it's a good idea I like it I like Rook
G8 you know
yeah if he does that we'll be so happy
like a queen here
Castle here thinking about the knights
again Queen here
he's like me he sees a lot of stuff it's
just it's not really there but it's good
to see things and
I don't know why we did this The Rook
everything was so solid Elena did you
just continue his plan this was like so
unnecessary I don't know what what
triggered this
I feel like we were we were going to
somewhere as a team we were on a journey
he realized it
oh
all right well this is actually getting
very dangerous for Tyler now
um there's a straight open file all I
need to do is like bring his Rook The
Bishop's already pointing towards the
pawns and he even push G5
fine
we should put squeaks volume on too
I think we can still hear Tyler although
he's not talking right now I'm not
serious oh he's talking there he is
oh can he hear us
no there is I this was I dude if I move
this here bro I know what I'm talking
about if I got these two on the same
line and I moved Queen down
Wards he's like visualizing a mate that
it'll take so much time okay good good
this is this is probably the best way
his King can run he needs that Rook on
that file wow I was just about to
highlight if squeak sees this check and
he played it before he could
but this is a good move he always missed
clicks I don't
just looks a little more complicated
League of Legends so yeah
yeah he's not ready for this LOL players
it's well known in The Gaming Community
or some of the laziest mousers in the
world
you know because it's like a wide open
map you can you can basically click
anywhere just in the general vicinity of
what you're trying to do not a lot of
mouse click accuracy required have you
ever played a game of League Danny
I have for the record I have watched
many people play
the game that I know good yeah I like
you could tell me anything about
it I'd be like yeah because I really
yeah it's just like an open map where
you throw Wizards and and dwarves and
goblins at each other and you just kind
of click and try to guide them toward a
victory it's not
they're just so funny it's it's really
not a big deal it's just like I'm not
trying to offend anybody I'm just saying
it's not it's not a super skill game
that's what I'm saying from what I've
observed okay
let's let's um let's look into let's
look into squeaks before I get into more
trouble let's get get me out of here
accidentally a genius here
whoops
all right let's think of the next move
uh
that's a wacky one
what am I falling for this Miss click
was actually such a good savings if I
take that Rook on that camera is so
important right now
on
well
didn't realize that one
Chad is pretty mad at me you can you can
hear League of Legends players guys it's
his first day on Twitch
moving their wizard moving their wizard
bobble head away from their keyboard so
they can bang it harder just like the
puzzle
Please Don't Go full screen right now
let's just watch the games
we've got we've got Checkmate on the
board by the way Ah that's why if squeak
sees it and he does
wow
squeeze wins he can't move here
you can't move here
wow look at her he solved it
oh
baby any more time playing chess
[Music]
[__] go
let's [__]
holy [__] that was a tough one man
God damn Tyler also played a good game
Billy just decided to randomly throw his
Bishop out the window I like he was
really doing well
all the all the all the joking and it's
just teasing aside Tyler was doing well
until he played Bishop D4 check it was
like out of nowhere just just it was
like yeah I'm bored of this I need
something new which honestly I get it I
get it chess does that to you sometimes
yep
it does that to you there's not as many
bright and pity pretty colors like there
are in League of Legends Maps so
sometimes it can it can make you go
crazy
um what was that but uh
we got two good polls going on number
one is does League require skill we got
66 no and the other one was a 600k
points to squeaks which um the the hole
was pretty divided it was 287
000 100 000 to 209 so
it wasn't let's see what time let's see
what Tyler's talking about now he might
he's he's reflecting on the game
commentary really pray he doesn't watch
the VOD before he even move this here
dude can we start
why are we stalling
plus this guy's ghosting for sure he he
knew my strategy ghoster
probably has [__] AI that has always
got a problem with something to do with
the chess game and it's never anything
to do with the actual moves just the
rules right he's he's claiming the uh
squeaks was sniping stream sniping
ghosting I don't know what that term is
I I guess they had a different
definition
I need some water
yeah I also did we just leave their
voices in the back guys I I genuinely
like Tyler's commentary because I think
we have the same approach to chess
oh man I just I think that that might be
true very Ultra aggressive you know not
always thinking things through Andrea
BOCES
but it might work yeah you just have to
out intimidate the opponent yep
a lot of mental games like if they could
see each other it'd be over if they
could hear each other absolutely over
all right yeah what
what do you say sorry
I I was I was about to wonder what
Tyler's saying and I think we're about
to go over there the uh the rules are
pretty bad you can't even move two
pieces every move that sounds like a
lull player complaining about the rules
well I have two legitimate misclicks
well Tyler needs to just do aim Labs
before
drop's not done
Focus true job is not done I want to see
a Tyler come back I I love squeaks is a
great player
I guess Tyler also kind of destroyed his
first match though so not to say that
he's an underdog
that's true
look at this move H3
that's a high class waiting move as we
like to call it
doesn't do a lot it doesn't do nothing
because I couldn't find any any
opponents it was bugged
yeah
I I don't got nothing to say that
um I thought he was gonna say I thought
he was gonna say he couldn't find any
opponent that was good enough to play
him I thought that's what he was gonna
say I mean that's actually also a fact
it is probably really hard like he goes
in the pool and he's like damn
these guys come I get it honestly that's
how my that's really the reason I
haven't been playing a lot of chess
online because I just can't find someone
as good as me it's really tough so I
just do other things now
me too that's why I also
stop playing chess I play Clash Royale
instead you know because it's more of a
challenge oh
I believe too
all right okay Jokes Aside this is a
good move from Tyler 95 centralizes the
pony he's also assaulted the king side
now at the pawn storm I'm digging it
yeah
I think we're going to tie breaks again
I'm calling it I think Tyler rebounds
yes and I'll trade one for one I'm a
Savage I don't give a [__]
yeah I agree with what he just said
didn't hear it Nothing Left to Lose I've
lost it all
doing pretty well
he loves to push these side pawns
um which aggressive that's all I have to
say doesn't always mean good but
the only thing I'm worried for Tyler is
because he's always pushing these pawns
man never really completes like King's
safety but it's because he's a Savage
and he doesn't give a fourth who do you
think is a better chance of winning me
against Tyler in Lowell or Tyler against
me and chess I guess we play 10 games
if we play 10 games of each I would
guarantee I have a better chance of
winning one game of League than he does
at chess
because we know what just is it's a game
of complete information like obviously
it's just like it doesn't really change
the odds I think but I think with League
at some point I'd figure out or get
lucky and put a wizard on the right spot
that's what I think
I think you got it
oh he pushes the F pod all day long and
this is not getting dangerous because if
we open up that night and let the queen
in which there was a lot of ways and it
might happen later King is thank you for
the arrows thank you Hikaru thanks you
too this could be very dangerous it
could even be a Checkmate in a couple
moves like he's actually planning it wow
wait squeaks I think squeak sees this
because he's pinning the knights so that
the Knight can take the night when it
comes day four and then the King has
nowhere to run
Masters if anything
if squeaks finds 94
Big Trouble in fact now if you could
drop the queen it would be Checkmate
because the bishop just took away this
okay he doesn't see it he gets castled I
don't know he might walk into it
yeah but this is the downside of Tyler's
very aggro opening is one side seeking
safety is much faster than the other
I will say this though even though F4
was super spicy from Tyler it's if it
doesn't get punished right if squeaks
doesn't see this idea it's not bad
because Tyler's gonna get a king side
attack with all the pawns so
well we you were manifesting a tie break
so I should have done that last time I'm
rooting for Tyler despite the haters out
there trying to create fake beef between
me and and E Rob's older brother if I go
here you know he takes yeah this is a
fight you guys don't want to see what
happened you don't know who could beat
the other one up like Tyler Tyler gotta
be careful you know so all right guys
he takes yep that's a good move and I'm
threatening this
he sees it now and it's just as powerful
actually because I also have this oh
yeah that's a good move well the problem
is he takes with this I also have uh
this yeah if Tyler takes it unless I'm
missing something I can't think that
Bishop that's gonna lose
the night right away
but if he takes it and and Anthony Rob's
older brother gives the check then I'm
just gonna call Tyler by his by his most
important claim to fame
that's it holy [__]
okay he took the right way
oh my God
wow
Tyler might take the bishop which
technically would work because you would
take the Rook out but this will start
getting very tricky
and if he moves The Rook Queen's coming
in ruining the yeah I think I'm in a
good spot hi who's in danger you're not
good enough it's not just because you
might have to fight Danny you know
honestly this wouldn't be too bad either
we've got uh
but but here's the thing squeaks has not
seen the queen check yet squeaks has has
not seen this idea yet so
we'll see
can we um also hear Tyler's audio here
this is very critical I don't know if
either of the players see the threat
here but this could be another decided
game and if if he escaped then we'll go
into tiebreakers
let's do it let's check out Tyler
I just spammed this last game
should it start spamming this
I think he heard what he said
I don't think he did I think his chat is
mad at me this Danny should not host who
is this guy
I didn't think squeak saw it he proves
he didn't and Tyler's position is
actually not that bad with the pawns but
as long as this check isn't played
so you saw the eval bar creep up like
it's that big of a difference the fact
that Queen H4 wasn't played means that
Tyler's position despite the fake beef
y'all are trying to create Tyler's
position is good and I'm rooting for tie
breaks let's go Tyler give me the dub
let's go let's go yep he has to kind of
leave that Bishop on B4
that's right people don't know that I
invented chess something's bad they're
like I could hear what I just try and
attack bro why don't I stop trying to
you know
at some point just.com made an IRL
version of it that's the game you play
on a board you know
no never mind
no you didn't no you didn't I hate you
anyway here we go what do we got
A3 I'm gonna chat as if it's his
children
Mom dad's being an idiot again
um here we go has invented chess I like
that A3 is a good move from Tyler and if
the trade happens the queen takes I
think the Tyler's position is much
better than what he had last game
so no I I mean Tyler is being a five
head Happening Here
if we weren't both Noobs
but it is for this like the fact that he
didn't trade the bishop and that he kept
the pressure was a very good intuition
because typically the 200 rated player
just wants to take everything they can
see but A3 was a very nice move like
this could be Tyler's comeback yeah no
he saw that if he took the queen would
have taken with check oop that's not how
you Queen moved in okay takes Queen
takes would have taken with check
and so he played A3 my mouse is like I'm
not I'm not that bad of a highlighter
here Carter would be real great get your
get your coloring books out Dan go back
to watching Vin Diesel movies
can you get some hearts in the chat for
Danny's commentary okay it's his first
time on the internet in like three years
guys come on be nice it's hard on your
dad he has four children he doesn't have
time for this he's running a company and
four children and you know what now he's
babysitting even more children
this is like the most fun I've had in
commentary probably because yeah I get
to say whatever I want and I'm not the
one getting in trouble yeah but I
enjoyed it I'm getting in trouble we're
having a great time though this is
actually great we got a lot of people
here I mean I don't even know who would
win in LOL I don't know how I won this
oh but somehow I'm beating you in Lull
oh they think you'll beat me alone that
means I get more lulls but I actually
think Denny's much funnier than me so
I think in League of Legends we would
actually be equal match up that would
actually be yeah Boomer versus Sumer and
neither of us not approve video games
actually Danny probably knows more than
me
I don't know how to play video games
honestly
all right all right yeah
he sees that he can keep being
aggressive over here
by the way hard I swear to God through
and if you didn't miss click it would
have been over minutes ago
just the way the world works
this Pawn is hanging that's the only
problem
but he plays F5 so Tyler's got the right
idea just I don't know if he's gonna put
it all together because even though
forget what the computer says I like
this idea because in pogchamp's chess
after takes takes takes we've got shake
and bake on the G file and this is the
way people lose weight so I I like what
he's doing
here so that maybe I'm not sure why I'm
using the the I like and what the
positions yeah he Robs a bigger brother
he played a chess he rubs your big
brother
you keep he probably won't but if he
does there's a bad move I'll take it
let's go big brother let's go
then what if I come on Tyler deeper
come on
E Rob E Rob
as the younger sibling with the more
famous older older sibling yeah you know
what I'm okay to chat Europe just this
is my moment too
younger siblings Unite
for the good of the community
Rob's Big Brother
okay if I move if I was to really spill
the beans I would say that the reason we
invited irav to the first POG Champs is
if you were trying to get Tyler and he
ghosted us he was Tyler was ghosting us
for the first POG champ so we invited
Iran I don't think he's ever gonna play
again after this one so you better
that is actually a true story we were
trying to get Tyler to play in the first
POG Champs and he ghosted us
he didn't see it he didn't see Rook C1
he but he sees you see some mate you
know well like only if he takes the pawn
I think that you were having some crazy
telepathy Talent there and you were
manifesting this but not like it really
doesn't do anything because black didn't
take the pawn
yeah but
unfortunately squeaks has to help e-rob
or sorry Tyler or he doesn't get
anything and but Rook to C1
that was the move that would have pinned
the bishop and won the game
yeah maybe Iran would have fortunate
Tyler just did it
hello
younger siblings tend to be better than
older siblings at most things so
at life
just life Okay the reason this is bad
though even though the computer says
that is only if he sees this but he
didn't so we're gonna see a lot of eval
bar swinging here everybody buckle up
but book of this you've got to love
Tyler's persistence he sees the G file
and he's all in on checkmate
oh oh okay don't take that pawn well
he'll be fine he'll be fine just don't
take the pawn just continue your plan
don't get distracted by the booba you
don't need to take it let's tune it to
Tyler
yeah there's a critical position
Wow Let's go he's staying focused good
the next turn I take this piece
let's Checkmate right
unless he does something with the queen
game over here unless he sees it he sees
the idea
sees the idea
we'll see if squeak sees Checkmate I
guess he could just take the queen with
this the queen we got Queen check though
wow
this one's my ear up
first time [__] let's go
I missed with the last round
he says he did misclick this game this
is what happens when the world just
works
Tyler lives Wow Let's go Tyler well
Danny was right we are going to
tiebreakers the most hype moments of POG
Champs they're gonna fight to the Dead
let's do it let's do it I was on time I
was on the Tyler one train despite all
the uh the haters in chat yeah
tiebreakers that was ridiculous by the
way he like he he was all in on the two
file plan you have to give it to him
Andre he was all in yeah he just kept
with it and eventually it worked out so
shout out to all those League of Legends
players out there who know how to use
the map good
yep yep
[Music]
we're headed to silent way we're going
to tie breaks get me off camera
okay we got three minutes plus five
seconds per move white is determined by
whoever had the more accurate chest
between the two games everybody when you
play on chess.com it gives you an
accident
we're gonna see it's gonna be super
close a coin flip between the bad chess
if the players are still tied after one
game we're just gonna switch colors and
do it again and we repeat that process
all night long until we get a winner so
this is it welcome to the most exciting
sporting event this is Tyler's favorite
part of Chess when things take really
long and you're doing it all night long
yeah that's what he likes he's into that
that doesn't sound good I don't know
well I have to say though you know just
Tyler I don't think he wants to play the
longer but somehow he keeps getting
these positions he had that 90 minute
game he has tie Breakers but I'm very
excited to see what he has cooking for
us and the game has begun actually it's
been fate that the one player who least
wants to play has had the longest days
either
Tyler is uh
okay squeaks got white by the way that
means squeaks played a little bit better
than Tyler on an average accuracy
so please check out what they're saying
I had more accuracy
keep abusing the most broken strategy
alive
I don't even know what that means I'm
gonna take it set the tone
you tell him
set the tone I came to play
this needs moves he did he came to play
let's just Castle again I bet you it's
Tyler castles like 90 chance he doesn't
get mated but
the man doesn't want to
the man doesn't want to he loves he
loves moving his knife twice before he
did like if that was the one tip I was
gonna give him he's played Knight D4 and
both times it sucked like don't play
that move bro
this is why he needs a father figure in
his life Danny that's why he needs a
father figure I can talk to him I've
already got four kids you know I think
it would be good
we're always like playing the London
this is not the London don't you slander
the London dude white is completely
winning what is happening well it's
because he's he's moving ever he's
moving all over the board instead of
getting developed this is a lesson to
all of you league players out there you
have to go with all the pieces you can't
just focus on one part of the Wizard's
spell okay trying to do a metaphor that
they would understand okay you can't
just focus on a wizard spell you have to
also do the queen Goblin move there you
go
notice they're in danger they like tread
away from it but then it just dives into
the fire like even myself you know I
learned my lessons once in a while
but let's see maybe he gets maybe Tyler
can Castle he has a he's feeling
shadowing his shadowing his Bishop
um
never mind yeah yeah no it's gonna move
attacks the queen let's go I give a
queen is good I'm a little worried about
him opening up his King again because
I'm just worried he's not in the castle
um yeah Redemption time let's move the
bishop let's let's let's bring back the
player's commentary it's great for this
game I like tuning in White's
practically completely winning but um
yeah this is only if there's perfect
play
let's see what squeaks has got squeaky
squeaky
come on squeaky
talk to us babe talk to me babe
no
switching that bourbon around his mouth
letting it sting his guns before it goes
down
I feel like I was in like a real man
getting better like a real man
there's a pretty fun check okay this is
actually good it has Maybe
file I wish my Rook was odd
let me do a double whammy
and bring them both in what if I do this
that we will shut Danny up for like a
long enough time to not get us into our
trouble
until the game's over
I appreciate what squeaks is doing
look I mean
as one guy who was born with receiving
hairline to another and squeeze
okay clearly this is this is something
that happens the stress on what if I
take this kills you he probably has kids
too that's why he's losing his hair
brown he goes here
um
look at this movie E5 move
yep it looks like Airlines the Secret's
a good chess it's not your IM this is
why I'm not that's right I was born with
a classic horseshoe pattern
classic receding hairline
um
Queen D7 from Tyler's not bad though if
he can get castle but if squeaks opens
it up
this is this is exactly what I didn't
want to happen Tyler got very distracted
started pushing the pawns and just
forgot to Castle but he's trying to
Castle queenside
um but it might be too late it might get
punished he might get squeezed
squeeze squeak skit and squeeze squeeze
squeaks squeak squeeze work incoming
yep
wow twitch did no one open the line of
fire at least they can take in it
easy on for Tyler
could have taken that pawn it would have
been big trouble yeah and Tyler now gets
out of it he takes that's actually huge
he's surviving because of that move too
by the way Ludwig Ludwig is watching is
watching POG Champs right now too we got
a lot we got a party going on everyone
better watch what you're saying Danny
yeah but wait you created a monster
yeah
from all responsibilities
by the way Tyler got castle that's what
I was saying now he did Castle into a
potential discovered check if white Seas
night check Rook takes queen that would
be insane yeah that'd be uh that'd be a
bit I mean okay but I can't take that so
I have to move this yep he's still
putting the pressure 96 would have been
just beautiful
dude I need them take I need these
pieces to move I need these to move
they act like I have no beef I literally
said the league takes no skill I didn't
say I want some of the clip that and
prove it to me I think I said League
takes less skill than chess did I say no
skill I don't know maybe
okay
what I do know is Tyler is showing some
chess skills all right he probably
studied with his little brother his
little brother gave him some tips
and now he's playing better yeah yeah I
got an idea
we're barging a hole through [__] it
here we go
wow squeaks is coming in just with an
army right now moving that Rook off the
file so now the bishop on D6 is only
defended once opening the way for the
Knight to move and open this lethal
battery
and I can move anywhere and open the bed
I'm just gonna keep highlighting you
don't like this commentary wait this is
not yeah yeah well this is actually
distracting move because if he would
have moved the Rook we've been a crazy
night check 97 it actually would have
won a piece
um but this is kind of forcing white
away from that tactic yes he's giving a
pawn but he's moved the queen so he's
not going to lose that Bishop so
actually five heads shot by Tyler trying
to save his Bishop
and Grandmaster commentary from Andrea
BOCES Hikaru Nakamura finally paying off
there in the background that was some
high-level tactics you spotted there
all right let's look into Tyler things
are getting tricky The Rook is hanging
but you know he's hoping he's gonna get
another mate on G2 but this time it's
defended
he better watch his clock
I'm suicide in this one
I think he meant sacrificing but that's
okay
just terminology we use fancy words ah
some people do that it's fine it's fine
it's fine
well uh don't put your king there you
know there's already a rook in your
queen right now you don't think we
should put the king here
and
no I can't I can't can't cause the Queen
the Queen's Queen
okay between the queen yeah and I like
that he's uh the queen he's got ideas if
you can play F5 like if we can get his
Queen over easy he can take now but it's
if Queen takes is his best bet oh my God
tanked upon oh my God looking at this
and then made on it too literally just
looking at this if I make him move it
one square deeper no
I know I'm
this what were you gonna say okay
or something yeah you're like I don't
want to get in trouble that's Danny's
job I know what you're about to say I
was so cool I was gonna say now I know
what Michaela feels like disappointed
I don't know I don't know anything about
the relationship just so close you just
had to get just a little deeper just the
goddamn pawn and then made on H2 Steve
Simpson dude what
no oh my God oh my God come on dude he's
a legend
twice as well for this two games in a
row
holy crap dude
[Laughter]
[Music]
actually insane
wow
I'm speechless
that boy thought huh oh man yeah they
love to hate me baby like I said if I've
been playing 35 years like you guys have
I'd be embarrassed not to be at the top
let's go baby
I don't know because those things you or
me or someone else no I don't know I'm
so I'm so happy for that win honestly
like that's insane that was insane
people think I'm hating this guy I love
this guy there's a reason we wanted to
buy him the first POG Champs but here we
go we got his little brother who did
great and now we've got Tyler this is
look I feel bad for squeaks because he
he literally played better
yeah he played great and then he
blundered Checkmate in both games it's
crazy
chest was so strong just for once like
and not only did he fall for this mate
once but the same mating pattern like
someone needs to show these kids to use
puzzle Rush sorry not kids sorry sorry
yeah no they are kids they're all kids
to me you know because I'm old
oh my gosh that was amazing let's bring
up the uh the group C scoreboard we see
that xqc hasn't even started playing yet
and I actually think he's probably the
best player in the group but you've got
tyler1 who takes down squeaks in tie
break fashion what in the world did we
just watch I pissed off thousands of
League of Legends players Tyler won this
is the greatest upset of the day Tyler
beating squeaks like no offense but he
came in with his very strong and big 199
rating and it was it was hard to believe
but Tyler impressed us all and respect
I'm very excited to see the next of his
games we're gonna get a tyler1 versus
xqc
I cannot wait I cannot wait to get Tyler
one versus xqc Tyler one versus anyone
from here on out sign me up for it
um and uh here he is with his uh
real-time reaction after taking it it's
amazing Tyler won his chest is reformed
squeaks is not as happy as he was in
that replay but don't go anywhere
everybody we still got more POG Champs
action ahead it's more pogchamps five
when we return in just a few
like
let's go
[Music]
accessible and why I've been using it
for a long time I mean if you look up
here I've actually have my streak it
says
1231 days right you're gonna forget a
lot of the things that are in the book
Jessica came around when I got
unjustable it's literally I was already
doing that so this is now a game changer
because I can do it faster it's online
it's in front of me all of my books are
here if they're gonna be folders now so
I can categorize my white black and all
tactics in game but I literally have
everything in one area as you see I'm
scrolling here this is what I like so
they're like how many testable books you
got I'm like all of them how are you
accessible is actually I do a lot for
the opening training I do tactics on
here I do calculation I do in-game I do
everything but the database all my
training on here all the time adjustable
is the wave this is why I like to use
child support actually helped me I
remember even online I was only like
tapping out at 23.50 almost 2400 and and
Blitz and bullet my chest com is 26 with
a high of 2774 on bullet and I blame all
of this if like success really it's just
working on chessable just being
[Music]
do you wish playing a chess game with a
friend was as easy as sending them a
text well good news now it is with
chess.com's new iMessage app you can
start and play a game directly in
iMessage your friend doesn't even need a
chess.com account it's just tap and play
head over to go.just.com iMessage or use
the command iMessage in chat to learn
more
oh I didn't even realize they started
they started and Charlie busts out the
uh the Dutch
the Dutch defense by Charlie and wait a
second has it free moved
this doesn't work
yes he has
entire King side development
those squares are moved with red have
you noticed Jimmy is making actual moves
have you seen
wow he lets his eye hold the pressure in
my hands
that's epic the future in my hands
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
there's Tyler one's reaction as he takes
it his chest is reformed along with that
workout shirt he's got a he's uh he's
all in it he wins in tie breaks over
squeaks it's hard to decide whether it
was a throw or a dub either way we had
great chess and great content Tyler the
chat is trying to create some fake beef
between US just because I said yes you
didn't want to see me win bro I could
see I played Flawless bets I have been
playing this game AQ for like five for
like five days maybe I played flawless I
was my gaming squeaks he was playing
checkers he was in the wrong game mode
squeaks you thought you had me a couple
of times bro I've been watching YouTube
shorts you're supposed to sack pieces
take some notes did you get code thing I
did it I'm self-taught I'm the best
squeaks Tyler got Tyler literally
classic tyler1 knowing one move and able
to Checkmate and that's what he
capitalizes on chess is a story yeah you
won this time but the second I figure
out how to stop that you're going down
making it to the next round bro are you
crazy I'm talking about you don't know
what this video doesn't show up again
which is viable he probably won't no
you'll get like a Pity around advance
but you don't want to see me around too
well I listen it clearly meant more to
you than it did to me you know what I
mean yeah
I did actually matter of fact and I'm
happy for you Tyler you know weirdly
awesome now good for you Tyler you
played great
of course I don't even know where to go
Andrea honestly it seems like we all
made amends a beautiful friendship was
born I think we can call it a successful
day ladies and gentlemen
and Tyler I want to say no matter what
Clips you might see there was no beef
here man the only beef is that chess is
much harder than league and I stand by
that but otherwise I played great that
was great I heard that you're the CEO of
Chess dude can we get an elec half
second undo button all right Miss click
four matches I just want to undo it real
real fast man okay okay if it's honestly
that's that's not a bad
yeah yeah not a bad feature request I
hear you I I second that it would never
move against the wrong Square in in IRL
chess don't say it she's like a oh like
half second that's fine it's fine
okay I think um Tyler also hates the
rule that you can stalemate even if
you're down a bunch of pieces we should
change that rule too while we're at it
so why don't we make the king stronger
what's that about you can tell he's
playing League he's like proposing
Tyler I wouldn't change that one
okay see look let's talk about you guys
are salty about this because I'm coming
in come here stop it it's fine it's fine
Tyler you and I are not so different you
know what I mean at the end of the day
it's you and me because I missed quick
bro you didn't you're you misclicked so
many times in a row like how many times
can we how many times can you say oh
like tough on the mouse or whatever you
can't miss click like seven times in a
row and blame the CEO of Chess yes I
can't because chess is too low APM I'm a
mobile player I have high APM chest like
oh move a piece you've got 60 seconds to
make to move a pot up one square bro I'm
eight minutes I'm calculated dude look
you just riled me up again it's fine
yeah it's fine we're fine I mean I
thought you play league not DOTA I
thought that was a real MOBA dude look
it's fine I'm just gonna say it's fine
he's trying to Rattle me up all right
all right go ahead enjoy the Poke the
bear all right Tyler so who wins between
you and e-rob by the way that's yes I
okay I lost to him last time I played my
brother but I was not focused I had
music playing chat 24-hour stream I was
playing I get the three match against
e-rob I beat him too easy
but don't bring that up please
okay good talk good talk good talk well
as uh
you know
um
I I don't even know what else to say
here this has been this has maybe been
the best day of POG Champs of all time
and and and uh okay I literally almost
called you you Rob I apologize Tyler
what do you want to say to everyone else
in this event about what happens if you
win this group are you going all the way
guys guys guys guys you don't want to
see me in the what quarters is that
what's next
semis semi borders you don't want to see
me in the next round I'm a menace all
right I artificially purposely hanked my
rank before the tournament so that they
would match me with easy people now I'm
coming with the Vengeance you don't want
me in the next round
Goliath games guy I don't care bro you
guys do this guy 30 years if you're not
just
making me say things I don't mean look
see bro is Miss clicking vocally
um
you guys we're gonna see in the next
round and enjoy I don't even know what
else to say I'm being told we got to
start the next match I would I would do
this all day but uh this was this was
entertaining and I don't even know what
else to say go go league go league go
League
have fun watching at home squeak space
but I'm still in the tournament hey but
Jesus that was pretty sick
all right here we go everybody Tyler won
and squeaks we're about to move on to
Jarvis where's the sky Kuno oh
[Applause]
Shadow and he made him proud today and
he made a name for himself that was the
first time Andrea botez has been
silenced on stream everyone take notes
it takes tyler1 to silence Andrea yes it
really is I didn't know it wasn't coming
for me or squeaks to you but I'm I'm
there are you not entertained are you
not entertained that was awesome and uh
somehow they were both right I mean
squeaks was right he was getting killed
and had one idea but Tyler won and what
are you gonna say so Tyler won one
yeah and just emphasize squeaks is still
in the tournament you will be seeing
more of squeaks yeah he's not going home
and by the way George Jones will be
going face to face with xqc
I that that is gonna break the internet
xqc tyler1 let's go by the way Jarvis
and Sky Kuno I think are literally
underway the game is either starting or
because that interview went so long but
either way it's our last match of the
day don't go anywhere
um you're probably already off work
because it's a Monday I don't know where
you are but stay with us here we go
there's more flies
this is ridiculous
oh my God there's like a there's like
you know like you find out that there
must be some like banana peel or
something in the room like someone left
yeah I think someone set you up then
there's a there's fruit flies in here
and it's driving me nuts we're back to
group a with Jarvis versus Sky Kuno and
Andrea who you got in this one we've
seen them both play so far I have a hard
time picking a favor here
you know some could say yes I couldn't
hasn't trained he's another but I think
that is actually what makes him fearless
and unpredictable against the
competition Jarvis doesn't know what to
expect and it's like you know at the end
of the day is a master of games so
anything could happen between taikuno
and Jarvis
yeah agreed well said way to not pick a
winner and give a politically correct
answer that was great that was awesome
you've learned from the best that's one
of my skills that's right you know what
happens rubbing off on you all right
here we go we've got Jarvis we've got
Sky cuno they're ready to rock how about
you
oh
right because I don't read good you know
I just Skype Uno and Snapchat
has already played you're right it is
skycuno there's no K before the Y I just
had to zoom in I didn't get my eyes
checked I am getting old
um it's Psy Kuno versus Jarvis it's
pogchamps five
these both of these players it's gonna
be a big a big change of pace from what
we what we saw with tyler1 they are very
refined and classy and slow oh
and we got a fun clown I take back what
I said and Jarvis doesn't return the
favor what a jerk I don't think he knows
the meme it's like when it doesn't what
this is of course I couldn't oh man this
I don't even know anymore
psychuno knows what he's doing he knows
that he played rooting for saikuno
because saikuno is a man of culture and
Jarvis didn't know the meme Harvest
needs to catch up on his chest memes
yeah I'm sure I'm sure Jarvis is just
like what the hell is this guy doing he
just gave me the pawn and his King's in
the middle of the board what the bleep
bro can we hear
inside kuno's audio on
we'll see I think it's like streaming or
is he on Zoom I don't know oh he's on
Zoom so we might have a little bit of a
delayed chat but I know the masses
um
huh hmm oh now he's just I'm okay okay
he's getting killed
if Jarvis sees Bishop G5 check it's
Rover this is so unfair
I feel like get a reason oh my gosh he
saw it on cloud okay Jarvis is the
favorite we now know
okay
move it up
wow oh okay well that's freaking bad
um okay
um huh
uh I think Jarvis
not looking good okay not not looking
good
um yeah okay wait if it was King of the
Hill if it was oh not anymore if it was
King of the Hill saikuna almost would
have won but not anymore
um what I could have should have look
Jarvis is a boxer he's worthless He's
Not Gonna Take It Easy oh
well uh I wasn't looking wasn't looking
we're about to get a uh we're about to
get a Checkmate here in the first five
minutes
you're down big time bro pretty down
pretty down I just wondering what Jarvis
must have been thinking when it's like
who know what king he said he's doing
here
oh oh I have to move this okay yeah
bonecloud isn't about winning it's about
sending a message a lot like when you
like in baseball when they throw at the
guy's head it's about it's about
changing the eye level sending a message
that's what bonecloud's about
saikuno knew that Hikaru was watching
today and he wanted to make him proud
and I get it you know sometimes you want
to earn someone's validation and his
opponent just reciprocal it's a much
deeper story than it seems like it's a
lot like you have a car there because of
your relationship with your dad and him
watching like you've got you've got a
lot of stuff going on in the
subconscious here yep
yeah it's deep yeah okay yes yeah you
know
um
looks like this game isn't going to be
that deep though I think Jarvis is going
to win very quickly it still looks very
very puzzled and very concentrated
let's think just think let's think still
playing like anything could happen
we
move the queen here it puts him in check
he can only move here
and then what do I do
um
um so I can check here
what does that check accomplish
um
I'm just going to keep winning free
material so may as well
like Uno has huge space Advantage though
true Dave true and he went he wins with
King of the Hill just like that
and it's Gigi in another in another
world
uh Pawn push take the knights Rook check
is that a is that a maiden two I think
it is okay yeah well we have made we
have made one on the board
oh there was amazing one the discovery
C4 is this just me as they say all right
hold on hold on here comes a boomer meme
hold on C4 is no he can move explosive
but it's still good
guys look psychic
an advanced game of chess that's gonna
come in 100 years
and you can undo a move within a few
seconds I actually think that's an
interesting rule amongst friends I think
we could allow it if it's friend versus
friend play I think allowing take backs
is something to to to bring in so I not
I wasn't just saying that too you
created chess so you just right
obviously snap your fingers and it's
done rules change just like that there's
we actually have an easy button in the
office and whenever I want I just walk
by and press the easy button and it's
just done that's what happens yeah
um got another mate Queen
we got three different ways to check
mate in one three different ways to
check
foreign
and he finds one of them just like that
well that was an interesting game well
that was anticlimactic and he's just I
get this
is that a dog asleep on the couch that
is so adorable ah that is huge
wow
Apostolic man you could say not even a
hooray
honestly no probably because saikuno is
100 rated doesn't feel too too
accomplish with him
shows up gets the job done is the only
way to make reparations is if Jarvis
starts the next game with bomb cloud
yeah I agree someone needs to give
Jarvis the tip that you uh
you know Unwritten rules of Chess if you
are offered a bond cloud
you accept the bone Club
yeah no Jarvis is a very strong
Contender so drivers that actually lost
his first match to Frank it was a crazy
match but Frank was a complete wild card
but I think if that wasn't happening
Jarvis could have been actually a
contender for first place so you know
normally that died he's so strong
not only that Jarvis took Sea Dog to
tiebreakers um and and I mean I think
Sea Dog is is one of the stronger
players in the event
um but uh but Jarvis I think I think she
does I think he took him to tiebreakers
I'm gonna double check that stat but I
think so yeah yeah he took Sea Dog to
tie breaks even though obviously Conor
still won so look at that they still got
the old Twitter logo here instead of the
X logo can we keep the Twitter logo
Forever Until Elon musk's Elon Musk sues
us that would be great actually I'm back
no I'm I'm sure I'm asking the team very
threatened I'm asking the team not to
change the Twitter logo in in Rebellion
to what's happening
um
I didn't I guess you don't have your own
twitch I was gonna say why aren't they
promoting my X account and just yours
because you because you actually stream
on Twitch I have a twitch that I haven't
streamed to in years but I still have a
few subscribers over there who just pay
monthly it's like a joke I have going on
and they're just renewing there's have
you ever shamed on there I I have
streamed back in the day
yeah
um well chess staff is keeping him away
from the go live button they're holding
him back
they're trying to keep me away from the
unfiltered on a stream of Consciousness
that would come out on on my stream
um I think we're starting the next game
so here we go saikuno now gets white
we'll see if he can rebound
um can we uh here's aikuno's commentary
as well
he actually has such a common commentary
that I I enjoy it even if the game
itself goes and takes a decisive turn
it's like the most relaxing chess
commentary I've ever heard
similar to Eric Rosen it's like it's
like ASMR ASMR chess commentary yeah I
think Chad needs it after hearing my
voice all day long
I wonder
I wonder how nobody has like really
jumped into the ASMR for chess thing
like people did some jokes about it but
like some in my stream
know what I do on the weekends okay
you've done ASMR chess commentary every
Saturday I whisper into the mic for
hours and yeah because I feel like it's
my way to give back because people
always like Andrea always damaging my
eardrums and I was like fine so I do
like a very serious weekly ice mushroom
wow and then that sounds that's
fantastic
I actually start a new YouTube channel
for it plus 2K Subs so far
you guys can all check it out real thing
I don't even know if you're joking but
if it's real check it out Yasser would
be great at ASMR by the way yeah
um I agree with that chat
um all right here we go psychuno doesn't
play the bond Cloud as white it makes me
think it was more of an accident that he
played King E7 I guess well actually we
can ask him
and I guess we'll never know
yeah we'll have some interview okay
because I like that he's trying to
cheese the opponent who is like clearly
you know like a thousand at least and
he's playing this night move trying to
threaten something on F7
um but now his Knight's actually in
danger and that is the reason you don't
want to over develop your pieces when
you haven't finished developing in the
in the opening
agreed Town Grand Master botez and now
H4 is played which protects the Knight
but actually if Jarvis sees Queen takes
G5 we might be headed uh oh we might be
headed for another quick one here this
is
this is getting spicy oh my gosh saikuno
is playing so fast he has more time than
he started with but it's not a good
thing he's not a Hikaru he's winning
this game in other worlds like reverse
chess he's beating the clock he's got
the he's got his own patch of Chess and
you know one day it's gonna be the next
big thing
oh
everyone claps in chat for saikuno
yeah
it went from slow Runner squeaks to
speedrunner saiguru I think it's an
amazing day
dude Jarvis feels no emotions it's like
it's like we're gonna ask him like hey
are you okay
[Laughter]
wow that was fast he's just tired of
beating up noobs well actually no he he
was he was kind of nervous had some very
challenging matches I think he's just
very uh strained player which I respect
yeah it's funny because he obviously won
this one too oh we know that saikuno is
is one of the the newer players to chess
but the fact that he barely lost to
Connor takes this one too it means that
Jarvis is a is a dark horse here in
group a to maybe be there we'll see
we'll see there you go I again wish
saikuno was in a different group because
I do think he has a lot of strengths
that apply to chess like right now just
speed running the whole game pretty
impressive you could say
um but Jarvis was a very very difficult
opponent and Jarvis has been playing in
chess club since he was a little kid
saikuno learned how the pieces move like
you know well he knew the pieces move
but he learned an opening maybe a week
ago so it's two very different skill
levels
yeah and uh that's what happens in chess
because there's
that's why you have me and he carves the
chest is all about our difference
it's all about the differences between
players sometimes and we celebrate those
differences exactly let's let's
celebrate group a right now with that
Victory Jarvis is in third place behind
Sea Dog and Frank have we seen group a
is group a come to completion here
and they all played each other
one more match okay wow Sea Dog vs Frank
that's gonna be an exciting one we have
the much
juicer stronger rated Sea Dog but Frank
the dynamite the Wild Card you don't
know what he could throw at you
yeah either with what he says or what he
does you never know with Frank what
you're gonna get next he's like a box of
chocolates you know as mom always said
you never know what you're gonna get and
uh that's group a
we're gonna we're gonna take a very
quick break when we come back we're
probably gonna have interviews maybe
with both with both Jarvis and saikuno
so don't go anywhere akara Nakamura is
going to refresh his coffee and when we
return It's the final moments of today's
POG Champs five match
foreign
[Music]
that comes to your mind uh the musical
and of course the board game
fantastic okay it's just a sport
absolutely very competitive known
worldwide uh battle of wits to the
highest degree I imagine this is the
best interview I've ever given howdy sir
I'm doing great are you an important
phone call
okay okay that's not the first time I've
had people hang up for me thank you
is chess a sport intellectually yes okay
kind of like the same type of sport
physically that NASCAR is okay does that
make sense I've actually never heard
that comparison as a guy who's been in
chest my whole life that's a great
comparison hi sir do you play chess
oh speak French okay on poisson
hey that guy was walking on passant
[Applause]
select the game chess I can beat you in
chess if you beat me I'll give you ten
dollars ten ten if you beat me I bet
okay I love it okay I'm gonna move my
Pawn out I don't know what you doing I
do know what I'm doing I don't know what
I'm doing it's all right that's all
right I don't know what I'm doing in
life
all right bro let's Checkmate oh
mate
hey bro I will unbelievable you got 30
seconds for me quick interview come on
you look like a chess player you play
chess don't play chess okay when I say
chess what's the first thing that comes
to your mind winning
of these three things one of them is
real
chest dancing chess climbing chest
boxing chest climbing chest climbing
chest dancing climbing chest climbing
chess books chest boxing chess boxing
you nailed it okay am I right for real
you nailed it seriously yeah of of the
two of us one of us is a World Chess
boxing champion which one do you think
it is
him with him the guy with the camera
yeah I'd like to say you but I'm gonna
go with Mr Man over the back okay easy
no he's not I mean he does get he tried
to hit another guy earlier so he looks
oh my God she didn't even hesitate from
now on will you stop making me do things
in New York
and Toronto where it's cold can we do
every on the street episode from here
from now on
my Lord the process here because when
you bring out the bishop like this uh it
can become very vulnerable right away so
I'm not sure that I like the like the
variational approach here
no please don't
and it's too soon I can't believe it
it's too soon
he just lost
yes yes yes yes yes
because he still has really good chances
what oh no a full blunder
oh my gosh she just resigned Hikaru we
got a resignation it's going to the tie
break
take the pawn oh boy it's the winner he
won by the dirty flag the question is
does hafu take the Grand Master approach
here and just take the Perpetual for the
championship doesn't matter
we gotta listen and she's about to
deliver the goods yeah
[Music]
holy [__] let's go
thank you
[Music]
let's go
we are back with pogchamps five our last
match of the day just wrapped up we've
got Jarvis and saikuno with us guys the
uh you guys have both come into this
thing and with different levels of Chess
right Jarvis you said you played as a
kid saikuno you're just getting going
good night they cannot hear you they
can't hear me they can use sign language
I am talking and I am I am verbalizing
uh Jarvis can you hear me
no no okay here we go we are still
rocking it
we're crushing it hey
um
we've um
yes
hello
you guys
oh right go back
Jarvis saikuno thank you for being with
us uh Jarvis we heard we were all kind
of talking at the break there tell
everybody about your history with the
game you said you were in chess club as
a kid and now you're excited
yeah I was kind of saying this during my
games with Frank because they were like
the first games that I played versus a
person and like almost 20 years because
I played I used to be in chess club when
I was 13 but I'm now 31 and I had not
played really any chess in the
intervening years so uh but it but it's
fun I have a lot of respect for the game
and it's like
um it's exciting to get back at it I
don't want to give like John's I don't
want to give uh excuses but I didn't get
a chance to practice before
um this event unfortunately I have like
a video deadline videos coming out today
so a little self promo but uh and so I
um I wish I didn't have my first game as
like a a game that was like knocking off
all the rest but you know uh that's
that's how that's how it goes sometimes
so I hope
I hope that as I sort of even though
I'll be in the secondary bracket I hope
I get to show off a little bit more uh
of like my potential
um as I get more time to like practice
that's a great attitude and honestly I
mean I think a lot of players are in the
same boat at the end of the day we have
a lot of very talented creators and
Jenny also doing it to practice she's
been traveling the world it's like Kudo
I don't know your excuse but is also a
busy man
oh I mean I think I found out I was
playing in this about three or four days
before I was
um and that's a very valid excuse
me I specifically said I was bad at
chess and here's what I was told the
only other contestant I knew was in it
was Leslie and I was like oh that sounds
super casual
um and uh well I've played against Conor
who beat Ludwig while being repeatedly
slapped
um
is a chess YouTuber apparently Jarvis is
probably the best guy I've played
against actually I that was the fastest
I think I've spent longer talking in the
past 10 seconds than I was in that whole
round so uh Jarvis is really good
but I mean
all I was gonna say is
I think you would surprise yourself if
you just took more time with your turns
that's all my that's the only thing I'll
say because I feel like you were playing
so fast that I was just like oh what's
going on
yeah I think I lost with more time than
I started with in the first round but
it's because I play a lot of places
I don't like waiting it's uh bad well
it's bad for chess it's good for other
things maybe
um it's like you know I know it's like
you said it's it's it's kind of tough um
to uh to play in a tournament when you
have a lot of practice but overall
though I do agree with Jarvis I mean I
think you see a lot of good ideas and I
think it's hard to slow down because
chess is a game where it's like the
opposite of the skill and the others but
that would be my advice too and I hope I
hope you're having a decent time even if
it's not exactly what you thought it was
going to be so
uh hey I won one round the other day oh
yeah
um you're are you familiar with the bomb
Cloud was that or were you flexing yeah
was that on purpose well so I saw a
video I was Googling guides last night
and there's this guy who said he got to
like 2 000 rating with the bong cloud
and I was like it must be good if you
got to 2 000 rating right or three
thousand years sorry three thousand no
and I was like Wow 3 000 is pretty high
so like it's got to be good if this guy
made it to 3 000. guys name is Hikaru I
think
okay
I mean you know I think this is honestly
a really good Strat yeah the guy who
gave you this advice we will find him
yeah pretty good yeah pretty good guy
well I bet you know if you keep up at it
I think you'll work eventually like you
know hikario didn't give up after his
first spawn Cloud he had a bomb Cloud
many times to reach 3000.
oh so I want to just say I don't know
about you saikuno but I have never been
like more nervous than I am playing
chess in front of twitch chat because
I've like I can't see it but I just I
can feel like my heart palpitating you
know what I mean like I I'm still
shaking now just like knowing that I'm
gonna have to talk to somebody about
what I did back there
yeah that was that was absolutely brutal
what you did there uh
sorry sorry I didn't know a good time
but I had one question for Jarvis every
time I've watched you play and you you
just win beautiful you don't even react
when you win like you're like a machine
which I have to say you're saying you
feel these emotions but you're probably
the most calm and collected player I
have ever seen well it's like Uno as
well but you don't even react after a
game's over I think I need I'm um
I think I'm trying to keep myself calm
because I am so like if you were inside
of my body it's kind of like and so I'm
just like yeah deep breaths you know
stay calm and then the curse hasn't even
broken when the game is over I'm still
like coming off of it so it takes me a
moment you know
um but I guess I've never been
if I I will say though
um if I were
if I had been playing chess more
regularly and I had a real good sense of
like what my ability was I think when I
did something amazing I would be like
super stoked on it you know what I mean
but but normally like the way that I
felt is I uh
uh I'm like don't [__] don't mess up
don't mess up even when
you know so I I feel like someone's put
me in an advantageous position or I have
a good move to make or in uh the game
with Conor I had an on passant and I was
like oh that's exciting it's exciting to
get an opportunity to do that but then I
was like oh oh oh
um is that even the right thing to do
what happens how am I gonna like make
this move and then lose in one turn
afterward that's like
that's my fear
it's funny we see that a lot because I
think players who don't play that much
chess you're like nervous you're gonna
go wrong even if you're seeing a lot of
good ideas so it's it's good confidence
but let me ask you both you got the
consolation bracket saikuno there's
there's time in this event you know um
do you want do you want some training
you and I could enter the bat cave and
you could come out a grand master is
that what you want
I mean I don't know is that how much how
much time we got left here like uh we
got
um
I'd like to win once maybe that'd be
nice don't think I will but well if you
want if you want some training some
coaching I'm I mean I'm I'm teasing but
I'm serious I think that is part of why
we do it because it's fun and chess is a
weird game that it you know it you know
can take can take there's some there's
some learning curves to it so if you
want Andrea coaches as well but I I
would I would I would probably have more
time and he actually invented chess and
he has four Grandmaster children so if
you were to take a lesson this guy's the
way to go wait is that true all your
children play chess like uh they all do
play but no no no they are not all they
are not all very good uh no
uh uh my my boys are fans of you right
so they'll be happy right we'll do we'll
do some chess lessons and then we'll and
then you'll come back and and do good in
the consolation
Jarvis oh okay yeah how you feel about
it
go ahead go ahead
oh no no house that was all
um
uh okay chess lessons are on the table
I feel good
just kidding go ahead well we'll see
we'll see I
um I uh you know yeah consolation
bracket I'm excited to plan it oh you
know the competitor in me is a little
bit disappointed that uh just how the
you know the cards Drew or whatever I I
didn't get to stay in this uh didn't get
to stay in the main bracket so I think
I've got a little chip on my shoulder
now so I wanna uh um
and I've got and I've got my video
coming out so I will have a free
schedule to to grind some puzzles to
play with some coaches so like actually
get down to it but I will say that like
this is really sparked like I remember
you know I think it was um in the game
with Sea Dog
uh I ended up like messing up something
in the in-game and ended up blundering
some pieces but I was up a queen uh and
and like the king queen in game to like
get checkmate I was like I don't know if
I remember how to do this I don't know
if this is the right strategy so I was
like doing this car and we were also low
on time so I was just like it was so
cathartic to be able to like figure
figure out the puzzle in the moment and
be like oh yeah like chess is super fun
I missed this game so if anything that
that's been a really valuable takeaway
from the tournament so far I love that
and Connor's one of the better players
and you took him to tie breaks so you're
I mean that was that was awesome so all
right well you got we got coaching we
got a lot of Chess ahead and remember
the winners the finals of the
consolation bracket is also going to be
in La which is fun we've never done a
live final before so there's all so
there's time there's time in the
consolation bracket to crush it you guys
have played a lot more games than anyone
else yet so
um saikuno right hit me up for chess
lessons if you're into it or not you
know Andrea you know Danny is a very
busy man so like don't even try I don't
even know if you know if you can time
the schedule you know it's hard not even
true that's not even true okay you know
I'm just easy I should find the guy who
did the bong Cloud I feel like he's he's
good yeah we should we should try wait
he's he's
at the World Cup right now in Turkey so
that's a problem
um and he's although he's also behind
Andrea there in her room which is one of
the creepiest things we're still trying
to unpack you know why she did that um
but he's behind Andrea there in the full
did you know that you also have a cut
out of his face I I thought you pulled
out okay it's not as creepy for me
though because I've owned I've I've
known him for a really long time so I'm
not as creepy as Andrea hey
almost my entire life so I feel like I
get some points for that one maybe I
could ask Papa botas to make you a favor
say Kuno but yeah he just got married
and stuff you know that's kind of got a
lot going on
what's the dog's name dog looks real
chill
his name is Dipper he went on a hike
today so he's a Dipper like the Big
Dipper yeah or if there are any Gravity
Falls fans like Dipper from the show
Gravity Falls but
um he's all tuckered out on uh from his
eyes yeah yeah he went on a hike today
and now he's just he's crashed like I
will right after the Stream
yeah all right we're gonna let you guys
go we do appreciate it and uh still more
POG Champs ahead and good luck to you
both
thank you guys for joining today we'll
catch you guys later I guess games
Jarvis
all right Andrea I think that one takes
the cake for the most awkward interview
out of the day you know I thought the
Jenny one I must no that was worse but
you know at the end of the day I have to
say Jarvis first of all you know excited
to see his video and you can tell he
really loves chess I'm excited for him
to take lessons and the reality of this
is chess is fun but it takes a lot of
freaking time to get good at I just want
to say my props go out to saikuno as
well
um you know we tease a lot but three
days before the whole last chest
tournament where you're paired against
all these chess Wizards is tough and
he's had a great attitude and I really
appreciate that from both of our
contenders I totally agree couldn't
agree more and it's not over yet I mean
there's still more time we're seeing
some fun moments here squeaks when he
got his dub versus Jenny earlier he was
pretty jazzed and then you've got Sat
Nav
getting the dog shout out to all the
napsters out there all the nappies the
nappy Napper snaps then you've got look
at yourself
good job
and Tyler Takes the Cake this guy was
out of his mind this guy is so funny oh
man this was so great well um we uh
livers we had some great interviews we
had some great chess some great games
today we should probably let everyone
know who's playing tomorrow right
because POG Champs is still rolling on
and Andrea bochas will be back with
commentary pretty sure they're putting
me back on the bench before I cause any
more problems I think I I don't think
I'm booked tomorrow I think it might be
Levy okay all right well either way
let's bring up the matchups because
today
is done but tomorrow is Tuesday we have
virtual versus ghastly you're gonna be
on the edge of your seat at home like a
mama bear rooting for you I am
to do some new prep because I'm not
gonna lie we were prepping for the cow
and he did not play the cow today so
Gastly studying though and virtual is
strong reading that Norwegian Ware got
Magnus Carlson in his back pocket yeah
go ahead Danny well no I was gonna say
he uh he is he is strong I think I think
he's still maybe the favorite in that
group but again sapnap proving that
wrong so but I did a thing he'll be back
with his sexy Australian accent and
he'll be taking on fusely I'm a sucker
for an Australian accent I'm just gonna
say it on camera you know yeah is NLB
our first fously debut tomorrow too yeah
Loosely making her debuts saikuno
shouted out Leslie and uh now Leslie
played in the first POG Champs too so
this is a return for her after after
many a year and then you've got Connor
and Frank which is actually the last
matchup in group a and really for all
the marbles there whoever wins that wins
group a so
there you go that's what's happening
tomorrow which is a Tuesday everyone
Tuesday is also the day when Title
Tuesday happens
Tuesday yes
maybe one one day Danny one day my
dreams maybe one day one of the best way
for you to get there is for you to
become a title player like why don't you
do it that way time for that
but maybe I'll try the bomb cloud the
3000 it could work
all right well while Andrea thinks about
how she's going to get in title Tuesday
let me remind everybody that we also
have the youth speed Chess Championship
going on you can watch all the action
we're in the semi-finals with fun Master
fun man about about to say something
else fun Master Mike and the co are
covering it it's on August 1st at 1pm
Eastern time that's when it starts and
so many of the top young players in the
world this is the future of speed chess
who will win the crown this is actually
exciting my nightmares like tests paired
against a bunch of like young kids
extremely skilled little kids like my
sister wanted to prank me she would just
throw me in a room with these guys
that's pretty awesome I didn't know you
guys are doing that maybe one first
match is fausti Oro versus Aaron Mendes
you can watch it at the twitch.tv chess
kid use the command yscc for more info
you know it's crazy these guys can play
in title Tuesday but I can't
you know what that's why I won't be here
tomorrow I'm just kidding
that's the best part about Chess you
know it transcends all those things but
all right we're gonna take a break today
was awesome Andrea this was a lot of fun
and uh yeah with the chill parent chat
will be back tomorrow with some very
exciting games and I will be back on
Wednesday
see you then everybody
oh no Hikaru fell
wait look at Julie oh God we're getting
checkmated
let's go I taught him so many principles
just for him to do this why complicated
check me right yes okay
yes let's go baby
[Music]
dude
wow okay well that's not too bad
oh my god dude Jarvis feels no emotion
we're gonna ask him like hey are you
okay
oh
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
the way through the window
thank you
[Music]
wake me up
amazing